I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello. Ho, ho, ho. Oh, you're really bringing it for classy Christmas part two. I am looking at my sweatshirt. Angela is wearing her Christmas sweatshirt, her sprinkles. Yes, it's a Christmas sweatshirt. It's my Christmas sprinkles sweatshirt. Which is available for purchase over at OfficeLadies.com, I believe. That's right. I love to dress for theme. You
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是好朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了这部终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士们。大家好。何，何，何。哦，你为“高级圣诞派对（下）”真是下足了功夫。我正在看我的运动衫。安吉拉穿着她的圣诞运动衫，上面有她的糖屑图案。对，这是一件圣诞运动衫。这是我的圣诞糖屑运动衫。我想可以在 OfficeLadies.com 上买到。没错。我喜欢配合主题着装。你
too. This is true. Well, today is season seven, episode 12. It was written by Mindy Kaling, directed by Rainn Wilson. It is part two of what we started last week. Since this episode is a continuation, I thought everyone might appreciate a little update on my legs. Oh, I thought you were going to update us on where we were at in the episode, but no. Oh, I will. Oh, yeah, we'll get to that. Don't you want to know about my legs if they're shaved or not? Did I get a razor in the mail like you suggested? Can I get a touch test? Well, I mean, you can see it. Let's see it. Hey, look at them shine of games. Yep. Just in time for fall weather. Oh yeah, just in time for short skirts. Gary being sarcastic. I am.
也是。确实如此。好吧，今天是第七季第十二集。由明迪·卡灵编剧，雷恩·威尔逊执导。这是我们上周开始的那集的下半部分。既然这集是上一集的延续，我想大家可能会想了解一下我腿部的最新情况。哦，我还以为你要给我们更新我们在这一集进度到哪了，结果并不是。哦，我会的。哦，对，我们会聊到那个的。难道你不想知道我的腿刮没刮毛吗？我有没有像你建议的那样收到寄来的剃须刀？我能接受触摸测试吗？好吧，我的意思是，你能看出来。让我们看看。嘿，看看它们闪闪发光的样子。 yep。正好赶上秋季天气。哦，对，正好赶上穿短裙。加里真是在说反话。我是认真的。
Second update, I think we're going to need to make sure that Cassie is still working on the clacky balls. Oh yes, the clacky balls that Toddler destroyed. The set up she has in here with the lamp, and it's the most focused I've ever seen her. Well, Cassie, if you untangle the balls, you need to break in immediately to the podcast. Don't wait. We want to know right away. It's a special announcement. Now that we got that out of the way, here's your summary. Remember Michael forced Pam to redo the Christmas party for Holly's return? Yeah, he wanted a classy Christmas. But he learned that Holly is still dating AJ. They live together. Yeah. Also, Jim and Dwight got in an epic snowball fight. Well, that's not going to quit.
第二个更新，我想我们需要确保卡西还在制作那些碰撞球。哦，对，就是那个被小背心毁掉的碰撞球。她在这里用台灯做好的摆设，这是我见过她最专注的一次。好吧，卡西，如果你解开了那些球，你需要立刻插话进播客。不要等。我们要马上知道。这是一个特别公告。既然我们把这些都交代了，下面是剧情概要。还记得迈克尔为了霍莉的回归，强迫帕姆重新办圣诞派对吗？对，他想要一个高级的圣诞派对。但他得知霍莉还在和AJ约会。他们住在一起。是的。还有，吉姆和德怀特展开了一场史诗级的雪球大战。嗯，这可不会停。
Daryl brought his daughter Jada to the Christmas party, and he's struggling to keep her entertained. In this episode, Angela's boyfriend, the senator, is going to show up at the party. Yes, he is. She's very proud. She's so smug about it. Except Oscar's pretty sure he's gay. Yeah. And then AJ is going to arrive to surprise Holly. That's what's going on. And you thought there wouldn't be any drama at the Christmas party? I know. Well, there wouldn't have been any drama at the first Christmas party. That's true. Fast fact number one, we had a fan mail flurry. It was all about that amazing comic book that Pam makes for Jim. You know the one, The Adventures of Jimmy Halpert.
达里尔带着他的女儿杰达去参加圣诞派对，他正费力地想让她开心起来。在这集里，安吉拉的男友——那位参议员，将出现在派对上。是的，他会的。她感到非常骄傲。她对此洋洋得意。除了奥斯卡很确凿地认为他是同性恋。对。然后AJ将赶来给霍莉一个惊喜。这就是剧情走向。你以为圣诞派对上不会有任何抓马吗？我知道。好吧，如果是在第一个圣诞派对上，本来是不会有任何抓马的。没错。趣事第一条，我们收到了粉丝来信的雪崩。全都是关于帕姆为吉姆画的那本神奇漫画书的。你知道那本，吉姆·哈珀特的冒险。
Yeah. He's the bear man. The bear man. In last week's episode, she showed it to Ryan, who didn't have a lot of nice things to say about it. No. This episode, she shows it to Phyllis. I titled that scene Phyllis Snark. We'll get to it. Yeah. But then she finally gives it to Jim. Yeah. The fan mail flurry was all about who created this comic book. Some people wanted to know, did I draw it? They had heard that I did used to do comic book art. You did comic book art. I have a little doodle you gave me. I saved all those years ago. You drew it on the set. You're very good. I got really into autobiographical comics for a period of time. Joe Matt was one of my favorites. And then I started kind of drawing
没错。他是熊人。熊人。在上周的那集里，她把它拿给瑞恩看，瑞恩对它可没什么好话。没有。这一集里，她把它拿给菲利斯看。我把那一幕命名为“菲利斯挖苦”。我们一会儿会讲到。对。但接着她终于把它给了吉姆。是的。粉丝来信的雪崩全都是关于这本漫画书是谁创作的。有些人想知道，是我画的吗？他们听说我以前确实画过漫画书艺术。你确实画过漫画书艺术。我有一张你给我的涂鸦。我多年前一直留着。你在片场画的。你画得很好。我有一段时间非常迷自传体漫画。乔·马特是我的最爱之一。然后我开始着手画
out basically almost like diary entries. So I had a little myself. I had a little you. Yeah. You had whoever. Yeah. Yeah. For this comic book, I will say I did not draw this. I'm not this good. You know, you see glimpses of it in the episode. It's very, very good. To find someone to do this comic book, Phil Shea reached out to a comic book shop called DJ's Universal Comics. And a woman there named Kat suggested that he reach out to a local comic book artist named Tone Rodriguez. Tone had been working on the Simpsons comics for several years, and she thought he might be a good choice. We reached out to Tone. Yes. And he told us his whole story. It is amazing. And I cannot wait to share. So Tone said one day, Phil just called
基本上几乎就像日记一样的条目。所以我有一个小小的自己。我有一个小小的你。是的。你有什么都有。是的。是的。对于这本漫画书，我要说，这不是我画的。我没这么好。你知道的，你在这一集里能惊鸿一瞥地看到它。它非常非常棒。为了找人来画这本漫画书，菲尔·谢联系了一家名叫DJ环球漫画的漫画书店。那里的一位名叫卡特的女士建议他联系一位名叫托尼·罗德里格斯的当地漫画家。托尼已经为《辛普森一家》漫画工作了好几年，她觉得他可能是一个不错的选择。我们联系了托尼。是的。他给我们讲了他的整个故事。这太惊艳了。我迫不及待地想分享。所以托尼说，有一天，菲尔突然
him out of the blue. It was a Wednesday. And Phil said, I need a comic book drawn up. And Tone said, well, when do you need it by? And Phil said Monday. And Tone didn't think he could do it. Yeah. He sort of said, I can't turn it around that quickly. But Phil said, why don't you come down to set so I can better explain what we need? Phil didn't tell him what show it was. So Tone didn't know. He knew he was drawing something for a TV show, but he didn't know what one. He said he got to the studio. Nobody was there. He said, there's no security. It was a weird part of town. Yeah. He said he just walked past the gate. And he started basically just wandering around. That sounds about right. Yeah, he was just asking, does anyone know someone named Phil?
给他打了电话。那是一个星期三。菲尔说，我需要画一本漫画书。托尼说，好吧，你什么时候要？菲尔说，星期一。托尼觉得他做不到。嗯。他有点像说，我没法这么快完成。但菲尔说，你为什么不来片场，这样我可以更好地向你解释我们需要什么？菲尔没有告诉他是什么节目。所以托尼不知道。他知道他在为一个电视节目画画，但他不知道是哪个。他说他到了工作室。一个人也没有。他说，没有安保。那是城镇的一个奇怪地区。是的。他说他只是走过了大门。然后他基本上就开始四处闲逛。这听起来差不多。是的，他只是在问，有人认识一个叫菲尔的人吗？
Phil. Finally, he made it to Phil's prop trailer where he got introduced to Paul Lieberstein. They started to explain what we needed. But then they said, you know what? This is really Mindy's episode. She wrote it. So we should check with her. Tone said by this point, he realized the show was called The Office, but he'd never seen it. He said he doesn't watch much TV because if he starts watching something, it really distracts him from his art. He has to focus. And so he doesn't get into television shows. Wow. I know, right? So they walk him on set to meet Mindy. And here's what he said. He said, I'll be 100% honest here. We were on set waiting for Mindy to give us a heads up on what she wanted for the
菲尔。最后，他来到了菲尔的道具房车，在那里他被引见给了保罗·利伯斯坦。他们开始解释我们需要什么。但随后他们说，你知道吗？这真的是明迪的一集。她写的。所以我们应该跟她确认一下。托尼说，到这个时候，他意识到这个节目叫《办公室》，但他从来没看过。他说他不怎么看电视，因为如果他开始看什么东西，那真的会分散他对艺术的注意力。他必须专注于此。所以他不会迷上电视节目。哇。我知道，对吧？所以他们带他去片场见明迪。以下是他说的话。他说，我在这里百分之百诚实。我们在片场等着明迪给我们透露一点她对
comic. And when she walked up to the three of us, I swear I have no recollection of what she had to say. Nothing. She walked up to us and it was like the scene in Wayne's world where Garth sees the woman in the donut shop, the light radiating from behind her, and you're hearing Dream Weaver by Gary Wright. Mindy was stunning. That's all I can say. She had me absolutely speechless and I have no idea what she might have said. I had never seen the show. Maybe if I had, I would not have been as surprised by her, but I was. Again, she was stunning. Oh my gosh, Mindy. So he says she explained everything she needed. And at the end of the encounter, she said, did you get that? And he said, yeah. And she said, all right. And she turned and walked away. And at that point, he said,
漫画的要求。当她向我们三人走来时，我发誓我对她要说的话完全没有任何记忆。什么都没有。她向我们走来，就像《韦恩的世界》里加思在甜甜圈店看到那个女性的场景一样，光芒从她身后放射出来，你听到的是加里·赖特的《追梦人》。明迪美得令人窒息。我只能说这些。她让我彻底说不出话来，我完全不知道她可能说了什么。我以前从未看过这个节目。也许如果我看过的话，我对她就不会那么震惊了，但我确实很震惊。再说一次，她美得令人窒息。哦，天哪，明迪。所以他说她解释了她需要的一切。在见面的最后，她说，你记下了吗？他说，是的。然后她说，好吧。然后她转身走开了。在那一刻，他说，
Phil and Paul turned to him and said, did you get that? And he said, I have no idea what she said. He was honest? Yes. And he said, they must have seen the effects she had on idiots like me before. Because at this point, they both said, yeah, we know, we wrote it down for you. Aw. And he said, that's a 100% true story. And then he said, my wife hates that story, huh? Mindy is someone, when you meet her, she just, she's a captivating person. Yes. I mean, she's beautiful and she has kind of an aura and she's confident. She's smart. Yes. I know. She's a force. She's a force. So I asked Tone, how many pages did you illustrate? And he said that he drew the cover and two interior pages. He said a full comic book is usually 22 pages. So that's why
菲尔和保罗转向他并说，你记下了吗？他说，我不知道她说了什么。他很诚实？是的。他说，他们以前一定见过她对像我这样的笨蛋所产生的影响。因为在这个时候，他们两个都说，是的，我们知道，我们为你写下来了。啊。他说，这是一个百分之百真实的的故事。然后他说，我妻子讨厌那个故事，哈哈。明迪是这样一个人，当你遇到她时，她就是，她是一个迷人的人。是的。我的意思是，她很漂亮，她有一种气场，而且她很自信。她很聪明。是的。我知道。她是一个力量。她是一个力量。所以我问托尼，你画了多少页？他说他画了封面和两个内页。他说一本完整的漫画书通常是22页。所以这就是为什么
he panicked when Phil said they needed it in a few days, because he couldn't do 22 pages. Right, right. But he said, after they explained what Mindy wanted, they said just two pages would be fine. And they would just duplicate them a couple of times to make it look like a full comic book. Tone said everything in the comic book is hand drawn, including the logo on the front. And he said all of the lettering inside was done by his buddy, Tony Fleece. And he said, people just, you didn't do it digitally back then. Everything was done by hand. By hand. Wow. And he said that the script inside all the words he took directly from the note that Phil and Paul had handed him after his meeting with Mindy. So that's it.
当菲尔说他们几天内就需要它时，他会恐慌，因为他做不出22页。对，对。但他说，在他们解释了明迪想要什么之后，他们说只要两页就可以了。他们只会把它们复制几次，让它看起来像一本完整的漫画书。托尼说，漫画书里的所有东西都是手绘的，包括正面的标志。他说里面所有的文字都是由他的死党托尼·弗利斯完成的。他说，人们只是，你当年不会数字创作。一切都是手工完成的。手工完成。哇。并且他说里面所有的字脚本都是他直接从菲尔和保罗在开完明迪的会后递给他的便条里拿来的。就是这样。
I love that story. You guys, a few years ago, I was at a comic convention in Philadelphia and I saw the comic book, The Adventures of Jimmy Hilpert. I was so excited by it that the vendor gave me two. I saved him. I brought him home. I gave one to Jenna. So Jenna has one and I have one. And I don't know if they're originals. I'm guessing they're not, right? Yeah. Tone said people come up to him all the time and tell him that they purchased one of the original props. And he said, I hate to disappoint people, but there were only eight of them that were made for the show. He said he has one. He gave two to one of his friends in Stockton, California. One to a fan in Bakersfield. He said there's maybe three original copies out there, but he does make replicas
我喜欢那个故事。你们，几年前，我在费城的一个动漫展上看到了那本漫画书《吉姆·希尔珀特的冒险》。我太激动了，以至于摊主给了我两本。我把它们保存了下来。我把它们带回家了。我给了珍娜一本。所以珍娜有一本，我有一本。我不知道它们是不是原版。我猜它们不是，对吧？是的。托尼说，人们总是走到他面前告诉他，他们买了一个原版道具。他说，我很讨厌让人失望，但为这个节目制作的只有八本。他说他有一本。他把两本给了他在加利福尼亚州斯托克顿的一个朋友。一本给了一个在贝克斯菲尔德的粉丝。他说外面可能只有三本原版副本，但他确实制作了这本书的复制品
of the book and he makes them available to different vendors at shows. Oh, that's fantastic. We'll have to share that in stories. Yes. He says there's an email you can use to contact him about getting one. We can put that in the show notes. He said they're limited, but you should but you should contact Jacob at that email address. It's manageink.art at gmail.com. But we'll put it in show notes. We will. But thank you, Tone, so much. Yes, Tone. Thank you. Thank you. I always love hearing stories like that. Me too. Well, fast fact number two comes to us from Stose B in Washington, D.C. This is a piece of fan mail that just absolutely warned my heart and it's episode specific and I can't wait to share it. Oh, Stose said, in all capitals,
并且他让展会上的不同摊主都可以买到。哦，太棒了。我们必须在故事中分享这一点。是的。他说有一个电子邮箱你可以用来联系他买一本。我们可以把它放在节目笔记中。他说数量有限，但你应该——但你应该通过那个电子邮件地址联系雅各布。是 manageink.art@gmail.com。但我们会把它放在节目笔记中的。我们会放的。非常感谢托尼，非常感谢。是的，托尼。谢谢你。谢谢你。我总是很喜欢听这样的故事。我也是。好吧，趣事第二条来自华盛顿特区的斯托斯·B。这是一封粉丝来信，它绝对温暖了我的心，而且它是特定于某一集的，我迫不及待地想分享它。哦，斯托斯全大写地写道，
my daughter was born to this episode of The Office. Oh my goodness. I've been waiting to tell this story since she was born on Christmas Eve in 2019. I went into labor with my first daughter on December 23rd and as soon as midnight on Christmas Eve hit, Comedy Central started playing The Office Christmas episodes on repeat. I kept them on all day and when the time came to push around 4 p.m., the nurses tried to turn the TV off, but I kept it on, using the episodes to keep me calm and focused for the next two hours. And the last thing I remember listening to is Oscar and Ryan's bit about bartending. It was truly the best way to bring my daughter into the world. Oh, I love that. That's hilarious and awesome. I love that she was like, no, you will not turn
我的女儿是伴随着这一集的《办公室》出生的。哦，天哪。自从她在2019年平安夜出生以来，我一直等着讲这个故事。我在12月23日怀上我的第一个女儿开始阵痛，一旦平安夜的午夜一到，喜剧中心频道就开始循环播放《办公室》的圣诞剧集。我让他们播放了一整天，当下午4点左右开始用力的时候，护士们试图关掉电视，但我一直开着，用这些剧集让我保持冷静并专注于接下来的两个小时。我记得听到的最后的事情是奥斯卡和瑞恩关于调酒的对话。这绝对是迎接我女儿来到这个世界的最好方式。哦，我喜欢这个。这太搞笑了，太棒了。我喜欢她当时的态度，不，你们不能关掉
that off. That's right. And now fast fact number three, Angela, is all you. You know, it's my favorite thing when you say, can I have a fast fact? Yes. And it actually pairs very nicely with Stose's story. Really? Yes. I'm intrigued. Well, my fast fact three is all about Ryan and his drink order of an F train to Brooklyn extra bidders. Okay. So you know, from that Office Tally interview, that was great, where Mindy said she made it up. Yeah, it was a made up drink, but she said BJ pitched the line with extra bidders. Yeah. So it got me curious if any component of this drink exists in the world, right? Okay. First thing, the F train is real. Oh, yeah. It goes to Brooklyn. That's right. It operates from 179th Street in Jamaica, Queens, all the way to Stillwell
那个。没错。现在是趣事第三条，安吉拉，全看你的了。你知道的，当你说“我能有一个趣事吗”时，这是我最喜欢的事。是的。而且它和斯托斯的的故事非常搭。真的吗？是的。我很感兴趣。好吧，我的趣事三全是关于瑞恩和他的饮料订单——一杯加量苦精的开往布鲁克林的F线地铁。好的。所以你知道，从那次很棒的Office Tally采访中，明迪说那是她编造的。是的，那是一种凭空捏造的饮料，但她说BJ提出了带额外苦精的台词。是的。所以我很好奇世界上是否存在这种饮料的任何成分，对吧？好的。第一件事，F线地铁是真的。哦，是的。它开往布鲁克林。没错。它从牙买加皇后区179街一直运行到
Avenue in Coney Island, Brooklyn. I've taken it many times. I have a friend who lives in Brooklyn, and all I know is if I get on the F train, I'll make it there. In fact, it was the first train I ever took all by myself. It was the first subway ride I ever took solo, the F train. Secondly, there is a real cocktail called the Brooklyn. There's not one called the F train to Brooklyn, but there is a cocktail called the Brooklyn. In fact, Jenna, did you know that there are cocktails named after four of the five New York boroughs? Well, I know there's a Manhattan and I love it. Yes. The cool thing about these drinks too is they date back to so long ago. I got to nerd out a little bit over cocktails and when they were created and the first time they were ever printed and
布鲁克林康尼岛的斯蒂尔韦尔大道。我坐过很多次。我有一个朋友住在布鲁克林，我所知道的就是如果我上了F线地铁，我就能到那儿。事实上，这是我生平第一次独自一人乘坐的火车。这是我第一次独自乘坐地铁，F线地铁。其次，有一种真正的鸡尾酒叫布鲁克林。没有叫开往布鲁克林的F线地铁的，但确实有一种鸡尾酒叫布鲁克林。事实上，珍娜，你知道吗，纽约五个行政区中有四个区是以鸡尾酒命名的？嗯，我知道有个曼哈顿，我很喜欢它。是的。这些饮料最酷的地方在于它们的历史可以追溯到很久很久以前。我得对鸡尾酒以及它们是什么时候被创造的、第一次被印刷出来的经历，稍微发挥一点书呆子气。
all that stuff. So here goes. Here are all the cocktails from New York City's boroughs. You've mentioned the Manhattan, probably the most famous one. It's composed of whiskey, sweet vermouth, bitters and typically served in a cocktail glass. Of the five drinks, it is the only one considered one of the quote, unforgettables on the IBA list of official cocktails. Oh, I see. Okay. The Manhattan is said to have originated at a banquet hosted by Lady Randolph Churchill at the Manhattan Club in the late 19th century. Oh, next up, there is a cocktail named the Bronx and the Bronx consists of gin, vermouth and orange juice. The Bronx was a pre-prohibition cocktail and it appears in the 1908 book, The World's Drinks and How to Mix Them. I'm intrigued. It sounds good. Next up, we have
所以开始了。以下是来自纽约市各个行政区的所有鸡尾酒。你提到了曼哈顿，可能是最有名的。它由威士忌、甜美艾酒、苦精组成，通常装在鸡尾酒杯中。在这五种饮料中，它是唯一被认为IBA官方鸡尾酒名单上所谓的“永恒经典”之一的饮料。哦，我明白了。好的。据说曼哈顿起源于19世纪末曼哈顿俱乐部由伦道夫·丘吉尔夫人主持的一个宴会。哦，接下来，有一种鸡尾酒叫布朗克斯，布朗克斯由杜松子酒、苦艾酒和橙汁组成。布朗克斯是一种禁酒令之前的鸡尾酒，它出现在1908年的书《世界的饮料以及如何调配它们》中。我很感兴趣。听起来不错。接下来，我们有
the Brooklyn, which is why we're here today. A Brooklyn consists of rye whiskey, dry vermouth, maraschino liqueur or maraschino cherries and a mere pecone. The Brooklyn first appeared in print in 1908 in Jacob A. Grohowski's book, Jack's Manual. Many cocktail experts, Jenna, feel like the Brooklyn fell out of favor because it has a fairly obscure component that's very hard to get in the United States. Is it the last thing you said? A mere pecone. It was a French aperitif. Oh, okay. I wonder if there's a substitute. I wonder what it tastes like. Well, people have substituted it with a different type of bitters, but it was very popular in the early 20th century and largely fell into obscurity after prohibition. I see. Next up, we have Queens, the cocktail.
布鲁克林，这就是我们今天来这里的目的。布鲁克林由黑麦威士忌、干苦艾酒、黑樱桃利口酒或黑樱桃以及阿梅尔·佩康（Amer Picon）组成。布鲁克林于1908年首次出现在雅各布·A·格罗霍夫斯基（Jacob A. Grohowski）的书《杰克手册》中。珍娜，许多鸡尾酒专家觉得布鲁克林失宠了，因为它含有一种在美国很难买到的相当晦涩的成分。是你说的那最后一样东西吗？阿梅尔·佩康。它是一种法国开胃酒。哦，好吧。我想知道有没有替代品。我想知道它尝起来是什么样的。嗯，人们用不同类型的苦精代替了它，但它在20世纪初非常受欢迎，并在禁酒令后基本上默默无闻了。我明白了。接下来，我们有
A Queens consists of gin vermouth and pineapple juice. This drink dates back to 1930, appearing in Harry Crottick's Savoy Cocktail Book. Isn't gin and vermouth martini? Isn't that what you make a martini out of? Yes. Right. Okay, so we're making a martini and then we're throwing a little pineapple juice in it. That's the Queens. Lastly, Staten Island is the only borough without a cocktail. Staten Island. I know, but there is a Staten Island fairy cocktail. Oh. And it's named after the fairy that carries passengers between the boroughs of Manhattan and Staten Island. It consists of Malibu rum and pineapple juice resembling a pina colada. And this is one of the things said about this drink. Its tropical flavoring is a satire on the fact that Staten
皇后区，这款鸡尾酒。皇后区由杜松子酒、苦艾酒和菠萝汁组成。这款饮料可以追溯到1930年，出现在哈里·克拉蒂克的《萨沃伊鸡尾酒书》中。杜松子酒和苦艾酒难道不是马提尼吗？马提尼不就是用这个做的吗？是的。对的。好吧，所以我们做一杯马提尼，然后往里面扔一点菠萝汁。那就是皇后区。最后，史坦顿岛是唯一没有鸡尾酒的行政区。史坦顿岛。我知道，但有一个史坦顿岛渡轮鸡尾酒。哦。它是以在曼哈顿和史坦顿岛之间运送乘客的渡轮命名的。它由马里布朗姆酒和菠萝汁组成，类似于Piña Colada。关于这款饮料有这样一种说法。它的热带风味是对史坦顿岛是一个岛屿这一事实的一种讽刺，
Island is an island, though far removed from the tropics. Oh my gosh. It's a little shade. A total disc drink. I know. So in doing all of this research, I discovered so many old, old books about the art of making cocktails, recipes, how to serve them. For example, the Brooklyn is featured in the book, Jack's Manual. If you go online and try to find it, there are a few original versions of this book. It's super old and they go for hundreds of dollars. I found one that was over $1,000 if you're a collector of these old mixology books. That's what I was going to say. What is Jack's Manual? Is it a drink manual? Yes. Cocktails. Cocktails. Oh, okay. I really wanted to see the original books and the pages
尽管它离热带很远。哦，天哪。真有点挖苦。完全是一杯贬低的饮料。我知道。所以在做所有这些研究时，我发现了这么多关于调酒艺术、食谱、如何服务的非常非常古老的书。例如，布鲁克林这款酒就出现在《杰克手册》这本书里。如果你上网试图找到它，这本书有几个原版。它超级老，而且要价几百美元。如果你是这些古老调酒书的收藏家，我发现了一本售价超过1,000美元的书。这就是我要说的。什么是《杰克手册》？它是一本酒水手册吗？是的。鸡尾酒。鸡尾酒。哦，好吧。我真的很想看看原版的书和书里的
of the books. And I found a website that's so cool. It's called EUVS Vintage Cocktail Books. They have gone and found these super old books and they've put them online as the images appear in the book. You know what I mean? And you click a little button and it makes a little page turn noise. And it's like you're flipping through the old book, ye oldie books. It was so cool. I'll put it in stories. So I have Jack's Manual. I have the actual original Brooklyn recipe that was in this book that was printed in 1908. I'll put it all in stories. I geeked out over it, but you guys, I'm not done. You thought I was done. I did. I did think you were done. No. Some of you may or may not know this,
书页。我发现了一个非常酷的网站。它叫EUVS老式鸡尾酒书。他们去找到了这些超级古老的书，并把它们作为书中的图片在线发布了。你知道我的意思吗？你点一个小按钮，它就会发出一个小小的翻页声音。就像你在翻阅古老的书，古老的书一样。太酷了。我会把它放在故事里。所以我有了《杰克手册》。我有了这本书里打印于1908年的实际原版布鲁克林食谱。我会把它们全部放在故事里。我为此着迷了一把，但是你们，我还没讲完。你以为我讲完了。我是这么想的。我是以为你讲完了。没有。你们有些人可能知道也可能不知道，
but my husband, Josh, used to bartend in his 20s and was a mixologist for a restaurant. Did he know any of these drinks? Has anyone walked in and said, give me a Brooklyn? No. He did not know the Brooklyn. He obviously knew the Manhattan, but I shared this whole story with him. He was part of this whole journey with me. And he said, you know, Ange, I would like to try a creating an F train to Brooklyn. Oh. With extra bitters. He took inspiration from the original Brooklyn recipe from 1908. Josh added his twist to it with a special ingredient, secret ingredient. He made the cocktail last night. I brought it here with me and I'm going to serve it to you.
但我的丈夫乔希，在他20多岁的时候当过调酒师，是一家餐厅的调酒师。他知道这些酒吗？有没有人走进来过说，给我一杯布鲁克林？没有。他不知道布鲁克林。他显然知道曼哈顿，但我把这个完整的故事分享给了他。他和我一起经历了这段完整的旅程。他说，你知道，安吉，我想尝试创作一款开往布鲁克林的F线地铁。哦。加量苦精。他从1908年的原版布鲁克林食谱中汲取了灵感。乔希用一种特殊的成分、秘密成分为它增添了自己的特色。他昨晚做了这款鸡尾酒。我把它带到这里来了，我要把它端给你们。
This is Josh's F train to Brooklyn extra bitters. I'm so excited. Will you remind me what is in a Brooklyn? Yes. Rai Whiskey, Driver Mouth, Merchina LeCour, and Amer Pecone. I'm very excited. This is the one, this is the one outside of the Manhattan that I was most interested in. This is just the thing Cassie needs to get that extra push to get these balls untangled. Okay. Here's the thing, you guys. It's going to take a minute of assembly. I mean, when Josh made it, it was beautiful. I mean, I have the shaker, I have instructions from him, and I have pictures of him making it. I'll share in stories.
这是乔希的开往布鲁克林的F线地铁加量苦精。我太兴奋了。你能提醒我布鲁克林里有什么吗？是的。黑麦威士忌、干苦艾酒、黑樱桃利口酒，以及阿梅尔·佩康。我很兴奋。这是除了曼哈顿之外，我最感兴趣的一款。这正是卡西需要的那种东西，能给她额外的推动力去解开这些球。好吧，事情是这样的，各位。这需要花一点时间组装。我的意思是，当乔希做的时候，它太漂亮了。我的意思是，我有雪克杯，我有他给我的说明，我还有他制作它的照片。我会在故事中分享。
Well, maybe we should take a break and when we come back, we'll all have our cocktail and let you know how it is. Yeah. And I will put this recipe on Office Ladies Pod, but I'm not going to tell it to you yet because I want you to have the reveal of the secret ingredient. I am very excited for this day. We'll be right back. Okay, we are back. Okay, I- Sam and Cassie are here. Hello. I have made Josh's F-Train to Brooklyn extra bitters. I want you guys to know one of the reasons why he jumped in as I started this endeavor is
好吧，也许我们应该休息一下，等我们回来的时候，我们都会喝上我们的鸡尾酒，并告诉你味道怎么样。是的。我会把这个食谱放在Office Ladies Pod上，但我现在不会告诉你，因为我想让你体验一下神秘成分的揭晓。我为这一天感到非常兴奋。我们马上回来。好的，我们回来了。好的，我——萨姆和卡西在这里。大家好。我已经做好了乔希的开往布鲁克林的F线地铁加量苦精。我想让你们知道他加入我这项努力的原因之一是
there's a special ingredient. It's the F ingredient. No, does this ingredient start with an F? Yes, it does. But I was starting to make this drink and Josh was like, that's going to be disgusting. I was doing my idea of it. He goes, you can't have another beet vodka. And I was like, wait, Sam liked the beet vodka. Very earthy. Very earthy. But anyway, so Josh was like, I'm going to step in. I'm going to have you try his version and then I'm going to tell you what my secret ingredient would have been. Okay, here you go. I want to say, I want to describe the drink. Yeah, remind me what's in it. It's very pretty. It's a sort of off pinkish color.
有一种特殊的成分。它是F开头的成分。不，这个成分是以F开头的吗？是的，它是。但我开始制作这款饮料时，乔希就像是，那会很难喝的。那是我的想法。他说，你不能再用甜菜伏特加了。我说，等等，萨姆喜欢甜菜伏特加。非常朴实的风味。非常朴实的风味。不管怎样，乔希就说，我要介入了。我要让你们尝尝他的版本，然后我再告诉你们我原本的秘密成分是什么。好了，给你。我想说，我想描述一下这款饮料。是的，提醒我里面有什么。它非常漂亮。它是一种偏粉红色的颜色。
It looks sort of like a dirty cosmopolitan and you've put even a cherry on two toothpicks. Because I didn't have a long toothpick. I've tried to make it fancy. Well, and you're serving it in a martini glass. Yes, I am. I'm very excited. Okay, cheers, you guys. I've trained a Brooklyn extra bitters. All right. That is a great cocktail. That's fantastic. I would order that any time. That's really great. Right? Do you like it? Do you like it, Cassie? Yes, I'm trying to guess what the F is. Okay. I have a guess. I have a guess.
它看起来有点像脏大都会（Dirty Cosmopolitan），你甚至在两根牙签上插了一颗樱桃。因为我没有长牙签。我试图让它看起来很fancy。好吧，而且你用马提尼酒杯端给它。是的，我是。我很兴奋。好的，干杯，各位。开往布鲁克林的F线地铁加量苦精。好的。那真是一款极好的鸡尾酒。太棒了。我随时都会点那个。真的太棒了。对吧？你喜欢吗？你喜欢吗，卡西？是的，我正试图猜那个F是什么。好吧。我有一个猜测。我有一个猜测。
I have a guess. Okay. Well, first of all, Angela threw us out of the recording studio because she said she didn't want us to know the secret ingredient. Uh-huh. But it makes a sound and we heard. Oh, I gave it away. Oh, I gave it away. So we're each going to write down what we think the F ingredient is. The F ingredient. So this was Josh's idea. I did not really know this at all. So this was all his idea. All right. Ready? Yeah. We're going to hold them up. One, two, three. Okay. I have a Fanta. I have a Fresca and I have a Fanta. It is Fresca. Fresca. Sam got it. So, yes. Here is Josh's recipe, you guys. And it's really good. He did one and a half ounces of rye whiskey, half an ounce of driver mousse, one fourth ounce of maraschino cherry juice,
我有一个猜测。好吧，首先，安吉拉把我们赶出了录音室，因为她说她不想让我们知道神秘成分。嗯哼。但它发出了声音，我们听到了。哦，我泄露了。哦，我泄露了。所以我们每个人都要写下我们认为的F成分是什么。F成分。所以这是乔希的主意。我对此真的完全不知道。所以这全都是他的主意。好了？准备好了吗？是的。我们要把它举起来。一，二，三。好的。我的是芬达。我的是雀巢冰爽茶（Fresca），我的是芬达。是雀巢冰爽茶。萨姆猜对了。所以，是的。这是乔希的食谱，各位。而且真的很好喝。他用了1.5盎司黑麦威士忌，0.5盎司干苦艾酒，0.25盎司黑樱桃汁，
two to three drops of bitters, Fresca. And he garnished it with a maraschino cherry. It's fantastic. So it doesn't have that weird French liqueur in it? No, you can't get it. And even that French liqueur isn't even made the same way anymore. So that's why this is the F-trained to Brooklyn and not the Brooklyn. That's right. I think Josh has invented a drink. Yeah. Tell him great job. And great job to you as well. Thank you. Well, guess what? When he stepped in, I was going to infuse rye whiskey with a fig. I had cut in half. He was like, no, no, no, Angel, you can't do that to them. And I was like, what? It could work. And he goes, it won't work. I think it could have worked.
2到3滴苦精，雀巢冰爽茶。他用一颗黑樱桃做装饰。太棒了。所以它里面没有那个奇怪的法国利口酒？不，你买不到了。而且那个法国利口酒现在制作方法也不一样了。所以这就是为什么这是开往布鲁克林的F线地铁，而不是布鲁克林。没错。我觉得乔希发明了一种饮料。是的。告诉他干得漂亮。你也很棒。谢谢。好吧，你猜怎么着？当他介入时，我本打算用无花果浸泡黑麦威士忌。我切成两半了。他就像，不，不，不，安吉，你不能对他们这样做。我说，什么？这行得通的。他说，行不通的。我觉得这本该行得通的。
He said it would have to be a dried fig. I was just chopping into a fig. Oh, he said it would get real funky. When you first set it in the booth, I was like, oh, God, fish. Oh, that was my first tea. Anything F. Yeah. Isn't that a great drink? This is fantastic. It's a great drink. Yeah. Well, way to go, Josh. Way to go, both of you. Thank you. I hope we all finish ours. And by the end of this episode, it's another one where we're all like, I love you guys. I love you so much. I love this pad.
他说那必须是干无花果。我只是在切无花果。哦，他说那会变得很怪异。当你刚把它放在隔间里时，我当时就想，哦，天哪，鱼。哦，那是我的第一个猜测。任何F开头的。是的。这不是一杯好喝的饮料吗？这太棒了。这是一款极好的饮料。是的。好吧，干得好，乔希。你们两个都干得好。谢谢。我希望我们都能喝完我们的。到这一集结束时，这是又一集，我们所有人都在说，我爱你们。我太爱你们了。我爱这个播客。
All right. Let's get back to the episode. Well, I'm very excited to break down this episode with my cocktail. I haven't even finished my cup of coffee yet. It's 10, 15 in the morning. You might have to do both. Okay. You might have to do caffeine and cocktail back and forth. Before we get into this episode, did you notice that the entire episode is only 18 minutes long? No. My daughter, Isabel, pointed it out to me. She said, Mom, that felt so short when we watched the second one. Okay. And I was like, it did. And she goes, Mom, can you see how long it was? Because I don't think it's as long as a regular episode. And I went and I checked and she was
好了。让我们回到这一集。好吧，我非常兴奋能用我的鸡尾酒来剖析这一集。我甚至还没喝完我的咖啡呢。现在是早上10点15分。你可能得两样都来。好吧。你可能得在咖啡和鸡尾酒之间来回切换。在我们进入这一集之前，你有没有注意到整集只有18分钟长？没有。我的女儿伊莎贝尔向我指出的。她说，妈妈，我们看第二部分时觉得好短啊。好吧。我说，确实很短。她说，妈妈，你能看看它有多长吗？因为我觉得它没有普通一集那么长。我去看了一下，她是对的。
right. It was 18 minutes. Hmm. So when it aired as one episode, obviously, it was a big episode. But when they split it in two, it wasn't quite enough for that full 22 minutes. It seems like maybe the first half ran a little longer. Yeah. They took up more time. I did notice that there's no traditional cold open here. We just pick up right where we left off in the last episode. Jim had broken the window and it's now been patched up with cardboard. It's still cold because everyone's had to put their coats on. I was so happy to stay filming.
它有18分钟。嗯。所以当它作为单集播出时，显然，它是一集大制作。但当他们把它分成两半时，它还不足以达到完整的22分钟。看起来好像第一半稍微长了一点。是的。他们占用了更多的时间。我确实注意到这里没有传统的冷开场。我们直接从上一集的结尾切入。吉姆打破了窗户，现在已经用纸板补上了。天气还是很冷，因为每个人都不得不穿上外套。我当时很高兴能继续拍摄。
I know. It was the one day we were actually warm. Oh, when they were like, you're going to wear a coat all day. I was like, woo-hoo! Woo! I noticed that the bass player is still there. Even after he was at a party where the window broke, he's going to keep playing the bass. I thought it was admirable. He's professional. Remember last week when I said he was played by Jonathan Pintoff, but that if you go to IMDB, this was his only credit? I asked Randy Cordray about that. He said that's because he wasn't an actor.
我知道。那是我们唯一一次真正暖和的日子。哦，当他们说，你一整天都要穿着外套时，我当时就想，呜呼！呜！我注意到贝斯手还在那儿。即使在窗户打破的派对之后，他还是要继续弹贝斯。我觉得这令人钦佩。他很专业。还记得上周我说他是由乔纳森·平托夫饰演的，但如果你去IMDB看，这是他唯一的演艺经历吗？我问了兰迪·科德雷这件事。他说那是因为他不是演员。
He was an actual accomplished professional bass player. He said we used our music contractor to hire someone to play the bass, and Jonathan worked with us for two days. He was so nice. I was stuck in the conference room for a lot of these scenes for those snowball fights were happening, and it was just really nice to get to know Jonathan and have a whole different energy on set, like a musician. You know, we also had a fan catch from Amelia G in New York for this scene. Amelia said, I love the details that go into each episode.
他是一位真正成就斐然的专业贝斯手。他说我们聘请了我们的音乐承包商来雇人弹贝斯，乔纳森和我们合作了两天。他太好了。在那些雪球大战发生的时候，我有很多时间都被困在会议室里，能有机会了解乔纳森并感受片场完全不同的能量——比如音乐家的能量，这真的很好。你知道，我们在这一集里还收到了来自纽约的阿梅莉亚·G的粉丝抓包。阿梅莉亚说，我喜欢每个细节融入每一集的过程。
I noticed that the boxes that Holly used to carry in her things are the boxes they used to cover up the window after Jim throws a snowball into it. Oh my God. Yeah, I checked. Same boxes. That's a applause catch. I know. Applause. Very good. Very, very good. Well, Michael and Holly are going to come together despite all their tension,
我注意到霍莉用来装她东西的那些箱子，就是吉姆把雪球扔进去后用来盖住窗户的那些箱子。哦，天哪。是的，我检查过了。一模一样的箱子。这是个值得鼓掌的发现。我知道。鼓掌。非常好。非常，非常棒。好吧，尽管存在所有的紧张气氛，迈克尔和霍莉还是要走到一起，
and they're going to reprimand Jim and Dwight. Jen is taking a sip of her cocktail. That's very good. They're going to reprimand Jim and Dwight, and they need to knock it off, right, before someone really gets hurt. Did you catch at one minute, seven seconds, when Holly says, Dwight's right. What you did was dangerous and inappropriate. I'm really surprised at you guys.
他们要训斥吉姆和德怀特。珍娜正在喝她的一口鸡尾酒。那非常好。他们要训斥吉姆和德怀特，他们需要适可而止，对吧，在有人真的受伤之前。你有没有注意到在1分7秒时，当霍莉说，德怀特是对的。你们做的事既危险又不得体。我对你们真的很惊讶。
Like, she's totally chastising Jim, but Jim is the one that has blood all over his shirt. Yes. Yes. And she's siding with Dwight. And then Michael makes up this whole elaborate story right on the spot. I couldn't believe how quickly he came up with the story. I felt like we needed to hear it, and then I need to share some candy bag alts for it. All this arguing reminds me of a very funny story.
就像，她完全在严厉斥责吉姆，但吉姆却是衬衫上沾满血的那个人。是的。是的。而且她站在德怀特那边。然后迈克尔当场编造了这么一个精心编排的故事。我简直不敢相信他想出这个故事的速度有多快。我觉得我们需要听听这个，然后我需要分享一些糖果包的备选台词。所有这些争吵让我想起了一个非常有趣的故事。
You see this on my desk? You know who gave me this? My girlfriend, Tara, who lives in New York City. Wait, what girlfriend? I haven't told you about her. I find that unlikely you email me when you get a new zit. I'm a man in my mid-40s, and I still get zits. I think that's pretty interesting, but you know what?
你看到我桌上的这个了吗？你知道谁给我的吗？我的女朋友塔拉，她住在纽约市。等等，什么女朋友？我没跟你说过她吗。我觉得不太可能，你一长粉刺就给我发邮件。我是一个40多岁的中年男子，我还是会长粉刺。我觉得这挺有趣的，但你知道吗？
I am not on trial here. The Scranton Strangler is. So anyway, we have this great weekend, and she drives me to the airport, and we get to JFK, but I am flying out of La Guardia. So we laugh and laugh and laugh, and then we spend the rest of the day walking around slow-mo, drinking latte, and at the end of the day, she gives me this, and she says, Michael, maybe next time, you should take a cab. I didn't know you had a girlfriend.
我不是在受审。斯克兰顿扼杀者才是。所以不管怎样，我们度过了一个美好的周末，她开车送我去机场，我们到了肯尼迪机场（JFK），但我是从拉瓜迪亚机场（La Guardia）飞的。所以我们笑啊笑啊笑，然后我们把剩下的一天时间花在慢动作散步、喝拿铁上，在一天结束时，她把这个给了我，她说，迈克尔，也许下次，你应该打车。我不知道你有女朋友。
I do. She is. I loved that couplet at the end because he's answering two things. Holly says, Michael, I didn't know you had a girlfriend, and he says, I do, but he's also answering the imaginary question, is she real? She is. So I went to the Candy Bag Alts to see if they had anything different in their life. They weren't in the script during his big speech, and they did, and it all centered over one line. So the line was, and my ticket was for La Guardia, and we laughed and laughed,
我有。她是。我喜欢结尾的那两句，因为他在回答两件事。霍莉说，迈克尔，我不知道你有女朋友，他说，我有，但他同时也在回答那个想象中的问题，她是真实的吗？她是。所以我去看了糖果包的备选台词，看看他们在生活中是否有任何不同。在他的长篇大论中，它们不在剧本里，但它们确实存在，而且全都围绕着一句台词。所以台词是，我的机票是去拉瓜迪亚的，我们笑啊笑，
and then he had three alts. Okay. Here's the first one. We laughed and laughed and spent the rest of the day eating hot dogs and Times Square. Okay. And we laughed and laughed and spent the rest of the day climbing the steps from Rocky. Okay. Which, by the way, different city.
然后他有三个备选项。好的。这是第一个。我们笑啊笑，把剩下的一天时间用来在时代广场吃热狗。好的。我们笑啊笑，把剩下的一天时间用来爬洛奇的台词台阶。好的。顺便说一句，那是不同的城市。
It is? That's in Philadelphia. I didn't know that. Yeah. Oh my gosh, that's so funny. Next one. And we laughed and laughed and spent the rest of the day making love on the top of the Empire State Building. I love walking slow mo.
是吗？那在费城。我不知道。是的。哦，天哪，太搞笑了。下一个。我们笑啊笑，把剩下的一天时间用来在帝国大厦顶上做爱。我喜欢慢动作走路。
I do too. In the next scene, Pam is going to show Phyllis her comic book. Yeah, and I'm guessing if anyone ever starts a conversation by saying, so you went homemade this year, that is some sass. Phyllis gave Michael a homemade oven mitt. Does she not remember? It doesn't matter for Phyllis. She's going to judge you.
我也是。在下一幕中，帕姆将把她的漫画书给菲利斯看。是的，我猜如果有人以“所以你今年搞了手工作品啊”这样的话开始对话，那绝对是带刺的。菲利斯送给迈克尔一个自制的隔热手套。她不记得了吗？对菲利斯来说这不重要。她会评判你的。
It doesn't matter. Also, she makes Ryan a homemade gift in this episode. Exactly. What's going on, Phyllis? I guess only your handmade gifts are worthwhile. Yeah. Well, the drama's going to crank up a notch because Holly's coming in wide open as my dad would say. Yeah, she's found her Woody doll.
这不重要。而且，她在这一集里给瑞恩做了一份手工作礼物。没错。菲利斯，怎么回事？我猜只有你的手工作礼物才有价值。嗯，抓马要升级了，因为用我爸爸的话说，霍莉正大步流星地走进来。是的，她找到了她的胡迪玩偶。
Remember at the end of last week's episode, Michael threw it in the trash and poured coffee over it? Hot coffee. Yeah, because AJ gave her the Woody doll and he was all upset. Well, she's found it and she is demanding to know who defaced the Woody doll. Phyllis really quickly says, well, Aaron doesn't seem to like you and then Toby's like, it sounds like it was Michael. Angela also agrees. Yeah, it was probably Michael.
还记得上周那一集的结尾，迈克尔把它扔进垃圾桶并倒了咖啡吗？热咖啡。是的，因为AJ送了她胡迪玩偶，他很不高兴。好吧，她找到了它，并且她质问是谁破坏了胡迪玩偶。菲利斯很快地说，好吧，艾琳似乎不太喜欢你，然后托比说，听起来像是迈克尔干的。安吉拉也表示赞同。是的，可能就是迈克尔。
Kevin in classic Kevin form says, wait guys, toy story is all about toys that come to life when people aren't looking. You don't think it's not possible that Woody did this to himself? This cracked me up, but also reminded me how the writers said with each season, Kevin just got more ridiculous. Yes. Well, I had a very, I don't know, odd catch as I was watching the scene. I just observed the number of poinsettia that we had on the set.
凯文以经典的凯文风格说，等等，各位，玩具总动员讲的就是玩具在人们不注意时会活过来的故事。你们不觉得胡迪自己干出这种事是有可能的吗？这把我逗笑了，但也让我想起了编剧们是如何说的，随着每一季的发展，凯文只会变得越来越荒谬。是的。好吧，我在看这一幕时有一个非常——我不知道，奇怪的发现。我只是观察了我们在片场摆放的圣诞红（poinsettia）的数量。
They were all white. They were everywhere. Last week we had a bunch. They were red and it just got me curious about the poinsettia. Oh, you're about to break it down. I'm going to have a sip of my cocktail. Go. Oh, in my research, I found out that poinsettia come in red, white, pink, purple,
它们全都是白色的。到处都是。上周我们有一堆红色的，这让我对圣诞红产生了好奇。哦，你准备好要剖析它了。我要喝一口我的鸡尾酒。请讲。哦，在我的研究中，我发现圣诞红有红色、白色、粉红色、紫色、
multicolor and salmon pink. Okay, I knew about salmon pink. I don't know how I knew that, but purple. Yeah, they are indigenous to Mexico and Central America. But here's the big thing. I always heard that if you have a cat, you can't have a poinsettia because they're poisonous. They're poisonous. Yes, I've heard that too.
多色和三文鱼粉。好吧，我知道三文鱼粉。我不知道我是怎么知道的，但还有紫色。是的，它们原产于墨西哥和中美洲。但最重要的一点是。我总是听说如果你养了猫，你就不能养圣诞红，因为它们有毒。它们是有毒的。是的，我也听说过这个。
Guess what? What? They are not poisonous. It is an urban legend, not poisonous, everybody. I guess that in the early 1900s, a boy was found dead in a wild poinsettia pasture. I don't know. And they assumed that he had eaten a leaf and it had poisoned him and he had died. And this just lived on in lore for years and years and years and years and years and years.
你猜怎么着？什么？它们没有毒。这是一个都市传说，没有毒，各位。我想在20世纪初，人们在一个野生的圣诞红牧场里发现了一个小男孩的尸体。我不知道。他们假设他吃了一片叶子，它毒死了他，然后他死了。这个传说世世代代流传了多年多年多年多年多年多年。
But according to poison.org, after many studies throughout history, no study has ever found the plant to actually be fatal. In fact, a study at Ohio State University showed that a 50-pound child would have to eat more than 500 poinsettia leaves to have any harmful effect at all. I mean, I feel like eating 500 leaves of most things would not be good. I think if you ate 500 daisies, you might not feel good, right? Here's what they said, quote, in most cases, exposure to any parts of the poinsettia plant in children or pets has very little,
但根据poison.org的说法，经过历史上多次研究，没有任何研究发现这种植物实际上是致命的。事实上，俄亥俄州立大学的一项研究表明，一个50磅重的孩子必须吃掉500多片圣诞红叶子才会产生任何有害影响。我的意思是，我觉得吃大多数东西的500片叶子都不会好受。我想如果你吃了500朵雏菊，你可能也会感觉不好，对吧？他们是这么说的，引述如下，“在大多数情况下，儿童或宠物接触圣诞红植物的任何部分几乎没有，
if any, effect. If swallowed, it may cause mild irritation, nausea, vomiting, or diarrhea. Touching it may cause a rash. There have been reports of gardeners who work with the plant frequently developing a rash from handling the plant. No death. No death for cats. No.
如果有的话，也只有很小的影响。如果吞食，可能会引起轻微刺激、恶心、呕吐或腹泻。触摸它可能会引起皮疹。据报道，经常使用这种植物的园丁因处理该植物而患上了皮疹。”没有死亡。猫不会死。没有。
For anybody. For people or pets or anything. You might get, you know, a cat who has some diarrhea. This is going to change my decorating this year. That's what I thought. I have avoided the poinsettia of my whole cat owning life. Yeah. There you go.
任何人。不管是人、宠物还是别的什么。你知道的，你可能会养一只拉肚子的猫。这会改变我今年的装饰风格。我是这么想的。在我养猫的整个大半生里，我都一直在避开圣诞红。好吧。那就对了。
There you go. I kept looking up various things because I was like, I don't want to get this wrong. You want to make sure. Don't put it out there. Poison.org and other websites. There you go. Right?
那就对了。我一直在查阅各种资料，因为我想，我可不想弄错。你得确保万无一失。可别把这东西放出去。Poison.org和其他网站。这就对了，对吧？
Yeah. Michael is going to fess up. He laughs. He's like, surprise. It was part of the party. Pretty funny, huh? Holly's like, you think this is funny? And then, oh my gosh, the groan factor.
对。迈克尔打算坦白了。他笑了。他好像在说，惊不惊喜。这也是派对的一部分。挺好笑的，对吧？霍莉的表情就像是，你觉得这很好笑？然后，天哪，大家齐刷刷地发出呻吟。
Michael says, I don't. But someday, I think we will laugh about this. When we tell our kids, everyone is like, ugh, I had to know. What did it say in the script at this moment? Because Jim says, yikes. Kevin says, oh no, that's not happening. Dwight says, dear God in heaven. I'm like, was that scripted?
迈克尔说，我不觉得。但总有一天，我想我们会笑着谈起这件事。当我们把这事讲给孩子们听时，所有人都一副，呃，我可得弄清楚。当时剧本里是怎么写的？因为吉姆说，哎呀。凯文说，哦不，这可不行。德怀特说，天哪上帝啊。我就想，那是剧本里写的吗？
That sounds not scripted. So I went to the script and it just simply said, everyone groans. So John, Brian, and Reigns improvs made it in. Very well done. I love that Dwight is like, dear God in heaven. Michael's going to start to spiral. He does that thing, Jenna, where he has his huge confession of his relationship in front of everyone.
听起来不像剧本里的。于是我去看了剧本，上面很简单地写着：所有人发出呻吟。所以，约翰、布莱恩和雷恩的即兴发挥被采纳了。干得太漂亮了。我好喜欢德怀特说的那句“天哪上帝啊”。迈克尔开始陷入抓狂。詹娜，他又做那个动作了，当着所有人的面把自己的恋情来了个大曝光。
He's like, I threw this whole party for you, the whole thing. Yeah. He's going to storm off to his office. Erin will follow. I have a random background catch. What is it? And I need your help out there, folks. I need your help.
他说，我为你们办了整个派对，整场活动全是我弄的。没错。他要气冲冲地跑回办公室。艾瑞娜会跟进去。我无意中发现了一个背景细节。是什么？我需要你们的帮助，各位。我需要你们的帮助。
At five minutes, 34 seconds. Did you all notice that little white Christmas tree on Michael's desk? It has like a silver base and it looks like it lights up. It's tiny. My grandmother had one. My grandmother, Kenzie, had one that she would sit on her end table. I've always wanted one. I feel like it's something you would get at Jenna's pouring herself some coffee.
在五分三十四秒的时候。大家有没有注意到迈克尔桌上那个白色的小圣诞树？它有一个银色的底座，看起来好像会发光。它太迷你了。我奶奶有一个。我奶奶，肯齐，有一个放在她的床头柜上。我一直想要一个。我觉得这绝对是你在……詹娜正在给自己倒咖啡。
I'm sorry. I have had so much of the cocktail. I'm feeling it. It's so good. I can't stop sipping it. Cassie is nodding and laughing. How are you guys doing in the booth? Great.
不好意思。我这鸡尾酒喝得有点多。后劲上来了。太好喝了。我忍不住一直抿。卡茜在点头笑。你们在导播间感觉怎么样？棒极了。
Yeah. Honestly, doing great. Happy Wednesday, everybody. I mean, it's. Oh, no, it's Friday now. Oh, no, it's Thursday. I said, happy Wednesday. It's also, it's 10.45.
对。说实话，棒呆了。大家周三快乐！等等。哦不，现在是星期五。哦不，现在是星期四。我说的是，周三快乐。而且，现在才十点四十五。
I said, happy Wednesday. It's so early. I'm sorry, Angela, to interrupt you. You want this Christmas tree, clearly. My grandmother had one and I can't find it. I do feel like it was like one of those Spencer Gifts kind of things, because I remember there was a little switch on the base and then it would all light up. There are two in this episode.
我说的是周三快乐。时间太早了。安吉拉，不好意思打断你。你显然很想要这棵圣诞树。我奶奶有一个，但我找不到了。我确实觉得它有点像那种斯宾塞礼品店（Spencer Gifts）买得到的小玩意儿，因为我记得底座上有一个小开关，然后它就会整体发光。这一集里出现了两个。
One on Michael's desk and where's the other one? I'm going to wait and reveal it. Oh, we're going to have to wait, folks. Michael's going to change out of his sassy Santa costume. Mm-hmm. Back into his street clothes. And Jim is going to find a gift on his desk. Two pickles from Swiss cheese.
一个在迈克尔的桌上，那另一个在哪儿？我要卖个关子，晚点再揭晓。哦，看来我们得等等了，各位。迈克尔要去换掉他的辣妹圣诞老人服装了。嗯哼。换回他日常穿的衣服。然后吉姆会在桌上发现一份礼物。两根瑞士奶酪腌黄瓜。
Yeah, it says, hey, pickles, Merry Christmas. Open immediately. Love Swiss cheese. I mean, what the heck? Swiss cheese? We had a fan mail flurry, Angela. Amy L. from Burlington, Ontario, Canada, and many others said, when Jim opens what he thinks is a gift from Pam, he reads the card.
对，上面写着，嘿，黄瓜，圣诞快乐。请立即拆开。爱你的瑞士奶酪。我的天哪，什么鬼？瑞士奶酪？安吉拉，我们收到了雪片般的粉丝来信。来自加拿大安大略省伯灵顿的艾米·L（Amy L.）以及许多其他人表示，当吉姆打开他以为是潘姆送的礼物时，他读了卡片。
Mm-hmm. You know, hey, pickles, blah, blah, blah, love Swiss cheese. Mm-hmm. That immediately made me think of when Michael called Pam's mom pickle during the boardroom scene of The Lover. What? Given how Pam felt about that relationship, I was surprised to hear that Jim and Pam adopted that term of endearment for themselves.
嗯哼。你知道的，嘿，黄瓜，巴拉巴拉，爱你的瑞士奶酪。嗯哼。这立刻让我想起迈克尔在《情人》一集的会议室场景中叫潘姆的妈妈“小黄瓜”的情形。什么？考虑到潘姆对那段关系的感受，听到吉姆和潘姆把这个亲昵称呼用在彼此身上，我感到很惊讶。
However, one theory is that after hearing Michael call Helene pickle, they ironically called each other pickle as a joke. What do you think? Yeah, the pickle threw me. I'm not going to lie, Amy. I like your theory that it became a joke between the two of them. I'll tell you what Mindy Kaling said. Oh.
不过有一种理论认为，在听到迈克尔叫海伦“小黄瓜”之后，他们俩是出于讽刺，才把对方开玩笑似地叫做“小黄瓜”。你们觉得呢？好吧，“小黄瓜”这个称呼确实把我弄糊涂了。艾米，我不瞒你说。我挺喜欢你的理论，觉得这成了他们俩之间的一个玩笑。我来告诉你曼迪·卡林是怎么说的。哦。
She said that when picking the names pickle and Swiss cheese, her requirements were, would I actually say this to a boyfriend? And is it nauseating to an outside person? Well, yes, to both, I guess. That's what she decided. That's how she was going to pick these pet names. It was not based on the Helene thing when Mindy was writing. I was very curious about pet names that you have for your significant other.
她说，在挑选“小黄瓜”和“瑞士奶酪”这两个名字时，她的要求是：我真的会对男朋友说这个吗？以及，局外人听到会觉得恶心吗？好吧，我想这两个答案都是肯定的。她就是这么决定的。这就是她挑选这些昵称的方式。曼迪在写剧本时，可不是根据海伦那个梗来定的。我对你们对另一半的昵称非常好奇。
Josh and I call each other babe. Babe. Babe. Babe. Babe. We say babe a lot. Lee and I call each other lover. You say lover.
我和乔希都叫对方“宝贝”（babe）。宝贝。宝贝。宝贝。宝贝。我们经常说“宝贝”。我和李叫对方“爱人”（lover）。你叫“lover”。
No, I'm teasing you because you hate it so much when people call each other lover. Well, listen, I did a show, Jenna knows that. I know. You shared it on the pod. Yeah, I did. Oh my God, it was so awkward. I would be sitting there on stage and they'd be like, lover, lover, you missed your lion lover.
不，我是在逗你，因为你超级讨厌别人叫对方“lover”。好吧，听着，我演过一个剧，詹娜知道这事的。我知道。你在播客里分享过。对，我分享过。天哪，太尴尬了。我当时坐在舞台上，他们就会说，爱人，爱人，你错过你的狮子了，爱人。
I'd be like, oh my God, please get me out of here. I think we call each other babe. Okay, so you say babe. Cassie, Sam, pet names that you've had for significant others. I'm just a big hun. This is real simple. Yeah, Cassie. I'm not a big nickname person.
我就想，天哪，请带我离开这儿吧。我觉得我们还是叫对方“babe”。好吧，所以你们叫“babe”。卡茜，萨姆，你们对另一半有什么昵称吗？我只是个大甜心（hun）。这很简单。对，卡茜。我不是个热衷于起昵称的人。
It's all business with Cassie. Well, yeah, it's all business or just shortening the name like Brian to Brie. Oh, I like that. That counts though. Actually, Brie counts. Okay. Lee sometimes calls me darlin' because he's from Texas. So I love it.
对卡茜来说一切公事公办。好吧，对，要么就是公事公办，要么就是把名字缩短，比如把布莱恩（Brian）叫成布丽（Brie）。哦，我喜欢这个。不过那也算昵称。其实，布丽算数。好吧。李有时会叫我“亲爱的”（darlin'），因为他是得克萨斯州人。所以我超爱这个。
Oh, when we were dating and he would call me darlin', it was just, it would have melt my heart. Swoon, just taking another sip of her cocktail. I'm literally going between cocktail and coffee. I don't know what's happening to me today. Well, I was very curious about these pet names and I found a fascinating survey. Dr. Tibido, you would love this. There is so much data.
噢，我们约会的时候，他叫我“亲爱的”，那简直了，心都要化了。陶醉中，她又抿了一口鸡尾酒。我简直是在鸡尾酒和咖啡之间反复横跳。我今天到底怎么了。总之，我对这些昵称非常好奇，我还找到了一项极其迷人的调查。蒂博多博士，你一定会爱死这个的。这里面的数据太多了。
It was on a website called theblacktux.com and I'm quoting them. They wrote, we surveyed 100 couples in all 50 United States and asked them, what pet name for your partner do you use most often? We then broke down the trends of these 5,000 responses by state, region, gender, and generation. Oh, that is fascinating. Yeah. There were lots of maps, lots of like percentages.
它来自一个叫theblacktux.com的网站，我来引用一下他们的话。他们写道：我们在全美50个州调查了100对情侣，问他们：你们最常对伴侣使用的昵称是什么？然后我们按州、地区、性别和世代，对这5,000份回复的趋势进行了细分。噢，太迷人了。对。里面有好多地图，还有好多百分比。
You'd really like it. I'll put it in stories, Jenna. But here we go. In 41 out of the 50 states, the reigning most popular pet name in the United States is drumroll, babe or baby. Second contender for most popular pet name in the United States is honey, hun, or honey bunch? Sam.
你会非常喜欢的。詹娜，我会把它发到快拍里。但接下来是重点。在全美50个州中的41个州，美国最流行的情侣昵称冠军是——敲黑板，babe或baby（宝贝）。全美第二受欢迎的情侣昵称候选是honey、hun或honey bunch（甜心、宝贝疙瘩）？萨姆。
Honey bunch. Honey bunch. And the third most popular is deer. They had so much data. It's really interesting. They had like Gen Z and the millennials. Like they had everybody, the boomers, like what they say. It was very interesting.
Honey bunch（小甜心）。Honey bunch。第三受欢迎的是deer（小鹿/亲爱的）。他们有太多的数据了。真的很有趣。他们甚至还划分了Z世代和千金世代。就像他们调查了所有人，包括婴儿潮一代，看他们都怎么称呼。非常有趣。
You know, something else happens in this scene. Jim opens the box and it is not a gift from Swiss cheese. It is a little mechanical catapult like snowball launcher. Yeah. Yeah. And it launches the snowball into Jim's face. This was another Phil Shea contraption where he had to hire the folks at hand prop room to create a tiny machine that didn't exist.
你知道这场戏里还发生了什么吗？吉姆打开了盒子，那根本不是瑞士奶酪送的礼物。而是一个微型机械弹射器，就像是雪球发射器。对。没错。它把雪球发射到了吉姆的脸上。这也是菲尔·谢伊（Phil Shea）的一个小发明，他不得不雇佣手工艺道具室（hand prop room）的人来创造一个原本不存在的微型机器。
These guys were asked a couple weeks ago to make a toilet paper deep plier and now they're making a tiny snowball launcher. A little catapult machine. I have a question for you. Okay. Is today Toby's favorite day of his life? He's holding court. People are hanging on his every word.
这些人在几周前刚被要求制作一个卫生纸解卷器，现在他们又在做一个微型雪球发射器。一个小型的弹射机器。我有个问题要问你们。好吧。今天算不算托比生命中最快乐的一天？他成了全场的焦点。大家都对他的话言听计从。
I think it is his favorite day. I mean, why are you laughing so hard? Are you drunk? No, I'm not yet, but I'm laughing because you went, you became when I was glitchy up in there in my closet. What? When we would record from our closets and I would have a time lapse because my Wi-Fi was so bad.
我觉得这绝对是他最快乐的一天。等等，你为什么笑得这么厉害？你喝醉了吗？不，我还没喝醉，但我笑是因为你刚才的表情，变得就像以前我在衣帽间里网卡的时候一样。什么？就是以前我们在衣帽间录节目时，因为我的Wi-Fi太差而出现画面延迟的时候。
You were just that but in real time. You went, is today Toby's favorite day? Like, no, I did not. It was really slow. You did a bit. It's that cocktail coffee combo. Oh, no. Oh, no.
你刚才就那样，不过是实时发生的。你刚才说的是：“今天……是……托比的……最快乐的一天？”不，我才没有！刚才语速真的超慢。你刚刚是在即兴模仿吧。这就是鸡尾酒和咖啡组合的威力。哦不。哦不。
You were traveling in the future and in the past through time. Oh, no. This is not good. We're not even halfway done. We might have to take a break and have some water. Yes, let us take a break. And have some water. And when we get back, we're going to,
你刚才在时空中进行了一场未来和过去的旅行。哦不。这可不妙。我们甚至连一半都没录完。我们可能得休息一下，喝点水了。是的，让我们休息一下。喝点水。等我们回来，我们要去……
I don't even know what we're going to do. Oh, we're going to go to the warehouse and meet a Grinch. We'll be right back. We are back. We have had water. We've had popcorn. We've had some veggie sticks, a cheese stick. Cassie got one ball free.
我都不知道接下来要干嘛。哦，我们要去仓库见一个格林奇（Grinch）。我们马上回来。我们回来了。我们喝了水。吃了爆米花。还吃了蔬菜条、奶酪棒。卡茜还拿了一个免费球。
Oh, yeah, we have a big update over the break. Mm-hmm. One ball is free. One of five. So, Angela, what's happening? I thought you were doing better. What? I am.
哦对，我们在中场休息时有个重大更新。嗯哼。有一个球是免费的。五个里面中了一个。所以，安吉拉，发生什么事了？我还以为你状态好点儿了呢。什么？我好多了。
Okay. Well, I'll tell you what's happening, Jenna. Yep. Jada is bored. And Daryl is scrambling, but Pam has an idea. And at six minutes, 41 seconds, as she walks into Daryl's office, there's another miniature white Christmas tree.
好吧。那我就来告诉你发生了什么，詹娜。没错。贾达（Jada）觉得无聊了。达里尔（Daryl）正在手忙脚乱，但潘姆有个主意。在六分四十一秒的时候，当她走进达里尔的办公室，那里又出现了一棵白色迷你圣诞树。
Where is it? On top of the water cooler. Oh, it's my grandmother's Christmas tree. Don't you wish you could just ask them if you could have it? They might have given it to you way back then, if you thought of it. I know, I know. Pam's idea is to lead Daryl and Jada down to the warehouse.
在哪儿？在饮水机顶部。哦，那是我奶奶的圣诞树！你难道不希望自己能直接开口问他们能不能把它送给你吗？如果你当时想到了的话，他们说不定很久以前就送给你了。我知道，我知道。潘姆的主意是带着达里尔和贾达去仓库。
There is Christmas music playing. There's a little, I don't know what you would call it, a tiny maze. Yeah. But not really a maze, but there's kind of Christmas garland and things. Yeah, it looks like they made an obstacle course of some kind, with warehouse stuff.
那里播放着圣诞音乐。有一个小小的——我不知道该怎么称呼它——一个微型迷宫。对。但其实也不算迷宫，不过挂着一些圣诞花环之类的东西。对，看起来他们用仓库的东西搭建了一个某种形式的障碍训练场。
And Andy comes around the corner of a stack of boxes, and he's got like, you know, a lot of coats on him. And he's done a makeshift Grinch costume, basically. And he says that someone has stolen the Christmas star. Yeah. Yeah, and maybe, maybe Jada can help find it. Yeah, she has to do a few challenges. Her face lights up.
然后安迪从一堆纸箱拐角处走出来，他身上套了好几件大衣。他基本上自制了一套格林奇的服装。他说有人偷走了圣诞星。对。没错，也许贾达可以帮忙把它找出来。对，她得完成几个挑战。她的脸瞬间亮了。
She's so excited. This is what she's been waiting for. Yeah. And then Andy says, you must answer topical political questions. How many congressmen in the state of Pennsylvania are guaranteed? And what other state has the equal number? She does not know. This is a record scratch moment.
她太兴奋了。这就是她一直在等待的。然后安迪说，你必须回答时政问题。宾夕法尼亚州有多少名国会议员是法定的？还有哪个州拥有相同数量的国会议员？她不知道。这是一个让人惊掉下巴的时刻。
Mm-hmm. What are these challenges? I was curious. I looked in the shooting draft as the scene continues, Andy tries to hint to Jada what the other state is. He won't let it go. Really? Yeah. She's like, I don't know.
嗯哼。这些都是什么挑战啊？我也很好奇。我看了拍摄剧本，随着场景的继续，安迪试图给贾达一些暗示，让她猜另一个州是什么。他就是不肯罢休。真的吗？对。贾达说，我不知道。
And he goes, come on. It starts with a I-E-L-E-I-L-I-N-I. And then Darrell's like, oh, man. And Andy is correct. I looked it up. Both Pennsylvania and Illinois have 18 congressional seats in the House of Representatives. I looked it up as well.
然后安迪说，拜托。它以一个“伊”开头，I-L-L-I-I-L-I-N-I。然后达里尔就说，哦，天哪。安迪说得没错。我查过了。宾夕法尼亚州和伊利诺伊州在众议院都有18个国会席位。我也查过了。
Oh, what you got? Well, I found out that California has the most. They have 53. Yes. I also learned that there are seven states that only have one. They are Alaska, Delaware, Montana, North Dakota, South Dakota, Vermont, and Wyoming. I found this very fascinating. It is fascinating.
哦，你查到了什么？嗯，我发现加利福尼亚州最多。他们有53个。我还了解到，有七个州只有1个席位。它们是阿拉斯加、特拉华、蒙大拿、北达科他、南达科他、佛蒙特和怀俄明。我觉得这太迷人了。确实很迷人。
You know, Pam says, maybe we could do this another way. Maybe Jada's going to look for it and you tell her if she's hot or cold. Yeah, that's a classic. Yeah. So he walks toward Jada and he says, you're getting warmer, warmer. You're red hot. It's right here in my coat. And the game's over.
你知道的，潘姆说，也许我们可以换个方式。也许让贾达去找，然后你告诉她离目标是热还是冷。对，这是经典玩法。对。于是他朝贾达走去，说道：你越来越热了，越来越热。你现在火热滚烫。就在我的外套里。游戏结束。
That lasted all of maybe two minutes. You know that Christmas music we hear in the background of the scene? No. There's a little bit of Christmas music. It sounded like it was from the Nutcracker. I asked Randy. He said, we paid $0 for the music in this scene because we reached out to the Universal Music Supervisor who provided us with a list of public domain Christmas tunes.
这个游戏总共也就持续了两分钟吧。你知道我们在场景背景中听到的圣诞音乐是什么吗？没有。有一小段圣诞音乐。听起来像是来自《胡桃夹子》。我问过兰迪了。他说，我们在这一幕中为音乐支付了0美元，因为我们联系了环球音乐主管，他们给我们提供了一份公共版权圣诞曲目的列表。
And then Randy sent me the list. Here's what you can sing for free, everybody, or play. Deck the halls, away in a manger. God rest you, merry gentlemen. Jingle bells, joy to the world. Oh, Christmas tree, silent night. We wish you a merry Christmas. Lots of songs.
然后兰迪把列表发给了我。各位，以下是你们可以免费演唱或播放的歌曲：普世欢腾（Deck the halls），平安夜（Away in a manger）。圣诞佳音（God rest you, merry gentlemen）。铃儿响叮当（Jingle bells），普世欢腾（Joy to the world）。哦，圣诞树，平安夜。祝你们圣诞快乐。有很多歌呢。
That's a lot. I think they were recordings of those songs that were public domain. Maybe I don't want to get anyone in trouble. You go singing things in a recording. But there was one song that I didn't recognize. Which one? It was called I Saw Three Ships. Did you look that up?
那可真不少。我想这些应该是那些属于公共版权的歌曲的录音。也许我可不想给任何人惹麻烦。你在录音里唱这些歌。但有一首歌我没听出来。哪一首？那首歌叫《我看见三艘船》（I Saw Three Ships）。你查过那个吗？
I did. And then I immediately recognized it as one of my favorite Christmas songs. And I'm going to play a clip for you. OK. Christmas day in the morning. Right? Yes. We love this song.
我查了。然后我立刻认出它是我最喜欢的圣诞歌曲之一。我要给你们放一段片段。好的。圣诞节的早晨。对吧？对。我们超爱这首歌。
We love this song. It's exactly what I thought it was. What's it played? Exactly. Our guests are about to arrive. First up, Senator Robert Lipton. Yes. You need to go to eight minutes 34 seconds.
我们超爱这首歌。这跟我猜的一 模一样。播放了什么？没错。我们的嘉宾快到了。首先登场的是参议员罗伯特·利普顿（Robert Lipton）。是的。你们得去看八分三十四秒。
If you want to see the happiest, I think we've ever seen Angela Martin. Oscar's going to introduce himself. He's going to shake hands with the senator. And then he's going to have a talking head. Yeah. He's going to say, Robert seems great. He's very handsome, firm handshake. He's gay, good sense of humor.
如果你想看到有史以来最高兴的安吉拉·马丁的话。奥斯卡要自我介绍了。他要和参议员握手。然后他会有一个访谈镜头。对。他要说，罗伯特看起来真不错。他很帅，握手很有力。他是同gay，幽默感很好。
And next, AJ is going to walk in the door. He's going to surprise Holly. Michael's going to come out. He's going to try to be the better man. He says, nice to see you again, AJ. Welcome. And he's like, good trip down. AJ's like, yeah, it was great.
接下来，AJ就要走进大门了。他要给霍莉一个惊喜。迈克尔要走出来了。他试图表现得更大度一些。他说，很高兴再次见到你，AJ。欢迎。他接着说，这一路开车挺顺吧。AJ说，对，挺好的。
Michael's like, good, good. Well, you know, have fun. Enjoy the partay. And then it cuts to Michael in his office. And he says, I am dead inside. That made me laugh so hard. I had to rewind it and watch it again. We had a fan question from Annie S. in Columbus, Ohio,
迈克尔说，那就好，那就好。行吧，好好玩。尽情享受派对吧。然后镜头切到了迈克尔的办公室。他说，我的内心已经死了。这段把我笑得直捶墙。我不得不倒回去又看了一遍。我们收到了来自俄亥俄州哥伦布市的粉丝安妮·S（Annie S.）的提问，
who said, AJ surprised us Holly by showing up at the office Christmas party. However, the party is supposed to be a surprise to impress Holly on the day she returns. How did AJ know about the party? He didn't seem to be surprised to walk into a belated Christmas party at all. I mean, don't you feel like she called him and said, things are going sideways here? Get over here.
她说，AJ通过在办公室圣诞派对上现身，给了霍莉一个惊喜。然而，这个派对本该是一个惊喜，好在霍莉回来的那天给给她留下深刻印象。AJ是怎么知道这个派对的？他走进一个补办的圣诞派对时，看起来一点也不觉得惊讶。我的天，难道你不觉得是霍莉打电话给他，说，这边情况不对劲，你快过来。
Oh, but he surprised her. Oh, yeah. I mean, if he was going to see her the day she came in town, wouldn't he have just driven with her? Why didn't he drive with her, by the way? If you were relocating to another city that was just a couple of hours away, wouldn't Josh drive you there? Yeah.
哦，但他还是给了她一个惊喜呀。哦，对啊。我是说，如果他打算在她回城的当天见她的话，他为什么不直接跟她一起开车过来？顺便说一句，他为什么不跟她一起开车呢？如果你要搬到一个离得只有几个小时车程的城市，难道乔希不会开车送你过去吗？对啊。
Right? Yeah. I mean, we already know things aren't going that great with AJ. He's about to get an ultimatum. Things are finally going to turn around for Daryl. He takes Jada to the break room and it's full of vending machines. She can't believe it. It's so awesome.
对吧？对。我的天，我们已经知道了，他和AJ的事情进展得并不顺利。他马上就要收到最后通牒了。达里尔的事情终于要时来运转了。他带着贾达来到休息室，那里摆满了自动售货机。她简直不敢相信。太棒了。
He has an idea. He's going to let her get whatever she wants, as many things as she wants. And then they become Santa's helpers. I loved this plot line. When I saw this, this 100% reminded me of the time that my dad brought me to work with him. And I had the same reaction to this room full of vending machines. Kids love to put the coins in a vending machine and press the buttons and see the little swirly thing, release the item.
他有个主意。他打算让她买任何她想要的，想买多少就买多少。然后他们就成了圣诞老人的助手。我太喜欢这个情节了。当我看到这一幕时，百分之百让我想起了我爸带我去上班的那次。我对满屋子的自动售货机也有同样的反应。小孩子们就是喜欢把硬币塞进自动售货机，按下按钮，看着那个小转盘把东西放出来。
Yeah. So if I could have stood at a wall of vending machines with a bag of money and just gotten things out, amazing. Amazing. This tracked for me. It was very sweet. Everyone starts opening gifts as well. Kevin got Oscar Ugg boots for his feet.
对啊。所以如果当时我能站在一墙的自动售货机前，手里拿着一袋钱，随心所欲地拿东西，那太棒了。太棒了。这太符合我的心思了。这非常温馨。大家也开始拆礼物了。凯文给奥斯卡弄了一双UGG雪地靴。
I love that Kevin's like, they're for your feet. Phyllis made Ryan a knitted iPad sleeve. Angela gives Creed a multi-pack of deodorant. Aaron gives Andy a card to help him stop biting his nails. And Jenna, Sam and Cassie. It's time for Santa Kins. What is going on today? It's Santa Kins.
我太喜欢凯文那种“这是给你的脚穿的”的语气了。菲利斯给瑞恩做了一个针织iPad保护套。安吉拉送给克里德一包多支装的除臭剂。阿伦送给安迪一张卡片，帮他戒掉咬指甲的习惯。还有珍娜、萨姆和卡西。圣诞老人金斯（Santa Kins）来啦。今天到底是什么情况？是圣诞老人金斯。
I don't know what this is, but. Santa Kins decided to get you guys gifts in two of the most unlikely places. Okay. CatCon and Martha Stewart. Wow. Yeah. A cocktail and presents. That's right, because it's classy Christmas.
我不知道这是什么，不过。圣诞老人金斯决定在两个最意想不到的地方给你们买礼物。好吧。CatCon猫咪展和玛莎·斯图尔特。哇。没错。鸡尾酒加礼物。没错，因为这是“优雅的圣诞节”。
All right. First of all, I went to CatCon. It's a convention for people who love cats. There's cats there. There's famous cats. There's every cat thing you could want. There's cat art. There's cat clothes.
好吧。首先，我去了CatCon。这是一个为爱猫人士举办的展会。那里有猫。有明星猫。有你想要的一切和猫有关的东西。有猫咪艺术品。有猫咪服装。
People dress as cats. Cassie just lit up. Uh-huh. And also they sponsor a huge cat adoption center. And almost 200 cats were adopted this year. So a lot of good things happening. It's great fun. And I bought you all gifts there.
人们扮成猫的样子。卡西顿时眼睛一亮。嗯哼。而且他们还赞助了一个巨大的猫咪领养中心，今年有近200只猫被领养了。所以有很多好事发生。真的非常有趣。我在那里给你们所有人都买了礼物。
And I'm going to start with CatCon. And then I'm going to move on to Martha. Cassie, I'll go with you next year. Because when Angela was describing CatCon to me, I was like, I want to go next year. Oh, our son, Cade, wants to go every year now. So we'll just get a group. My daughter will want to go to this as well.
我要从CatCon开始。然后我再去玛莎那里。卡西，我明年跟你一起去。因为当安吉拉向我描述CatCon时，我就想明年去。噢，我们的儿子凯德现在想每年都去。所以我们组个团吧。我女儿也会想去这里的。
Yeah. And you dress up. I wore CatEars. Like you just go for it. I just want to make sure everybody understands that Angela was just a guest at CatCon. She wasn't speaking there. No.
对。而且你们要盛装打扮。我戴了猫耳朵。就得豁出去。我只想确保大家都明白，安吉拉当时只是CatCon的普通观众。她不是去那儿演讲的。没有。
Making any kind of professional appearance. No. This was not a work gig in any way. She was. We just wanted to go see cats. Yep. We did. And then I bought a lot of stuff.
也没有进行任何形式的专业出镜。没有。这在任何方面都不是工作演出。她是。我们只是想去看猫。没错。我们确实去了。然后我买了很多东西。
All right. So Jenna, go first. All right. This is from an artist that all she does, you guys, for the most part, are cats and plants. So you know, I loved it. I had to get one that resembled Oreo and Jenna. It's Sunny Cat.
好啦。珍娜，你先来。好。这是来自一位艺术家的作品，你们知道吗，她基本上所有的作品都是猫和植物。所以你们懂的，我太喜欢了。我必须买一个长得像奥利奥和珍娜的。珍娜，这是阳光猫。
It's so cute. It's so cute. Oh, my God. It's an orange kitty cat laying in a box. Yes. I love it. So fond of this. And he barely fits.
太可爱了。太可爱了。天哪。是一只趴在盒子里的橘猫。是的。我太喜欢了。太喜欢这个了。而且它勉强挤进去。
So I feel like he's that hashtag, if I fits, I sits. Yes. And that's by this artist named Lisa. She was lovely. All right. Cassie, go. Okay. Cassie got a cat wallet.
所以我感觉它就像那个话题标签，只要我能塞进去，我就能坐下。没错。那是出自一位名叫莉萨的艺术家之手。她人特别好。好啦，卡西，你来。好吧。卡西得到了一个猫咪钱包。
It's so cute. It's really cute. Oh, my gosh. It's a little cat wallet. It's got little kitties all over it. It's very cute. And then Sam, you got the most random. But it's very, very funny.
太可爱了。真的超可爱。天哪。是个小猫钱包。上面到处都是小猫咪。非常可爱。然后是萨姆，你拿到了最随机的礼物。但是非常非常搞笑。
Sam does not have a cat. Okay. You guys should know the Australian firefighters do a calendar every year where the hottest firefighters hold kittens. I met all of them. I got their calendar. Oh, my gosh.
萨姆并没有养猫。好吧。你们应该都知道，澳大利亚消防员每年都会出一本挂历，上面是最性感的消防员抱着小猫。我见过他们所有人。我拿到了他们的挂历。哦，天哪。
I mean this without sarcasm. Sometimes when people enter my home, I think, how will they know I'm bisexual? No. It's a slam dunk. I know. They are so hot and they were so nice. When people ask my sexuality,
我这话绝对不是讽刺。有时当人们走进我家时，我想，他们怎么才知道我是双性恋？不。这绝对是一目了然。我知道。他们太性感了，人也超级好。当人们问我的性取向时，
it's this calendar. So cute. The kittens are really cute. They raise money for kitten rescue. And then Sam, for your walks, I got you. And you can take it to a concert, Sam. Oh, because it's clear? Yes.
就是这本挂历。太可爱了。小猫真的好可爱。他们为小猫救援筹集资金。然后是萨姆，为了你散步时用，我给你准备了这个，你可以带着它去演唱会，萨姆。哦，因为它是透明的？对。
For everyone at home. It's a clear, shiny fanny pad. Yes, because if you go to a concert and I know you like to go, you have to have a clear bag. I learned that. We just went to one. Oh, yeah.
告诉电视机前的各位。这是一个透明闪亮的腰包。对，因为如果你去演唱会——我知道你喜欢去——你必须带一个透明包。我学到了。我们刚去过一个。哦，对。
I bumped into Cassie at the Killers downtown we're playing. And it was a, did you see the pile of purses outside the metal detector for people who didn't want to go back to their car? But look, Sam. I know. For a great cat.
杀手乐队在市中心演出时，我在那儿碰到了卡西。当时——你看到金属探测器外面堆了一堆钱包吗，都是那些不想回车里去的人留下的？但是看，萨姆。我知道。为了一个伟大的猫奴。
This is the world's best cat litter. This will be attending some raves. And I will send you many pictures. Okay, great. So a few years ago, I went to a food festival. Martha Stewart was a key speaker. Everyone on her staff had to wear a puffer vest t-shirt. It's a t-shirt, but it's a puffer vest.
这是世上最好的猫砂。这个将出席一些狂欢派对。我会给你发很多照片的。好的，太棒了。所以几年前，我去参加了一个美食节。玛莎·斯图尔特是主要演讲嘉宾。她手下的每个人都必须穿一件羽绒马甲T恤。这是一件T恤，但它是一件羽绒马甲。
I don't understand. Martha loves them. They're part of her fall collection. I didn't understand either. She couldn't stop talking about them. She'd be like, have you all looked at my puffer vest on the t-shirt? Cecile over here is wearing maroon.
我不明白。玛莎很喜欢它们。这是她秋季系列的一部分。我也不懂。她不停地谈论它们。她会说，你们都看过我那件羽绒马甲T恤了吗？这边的塞西尔穿的是栗色。
I think it looks amazing. I am in the green. That's my Martha. That's a really good- Spot on, Martha. Yeah, there you go. Yes. She also shared that she likes her hens to have
我觉得看起来棒极了。我穿的是绿色。这就是我的玛莎。模仿得真像——太传神了，玛莎。对，就是这样。没错。她还分享说她喜欢她的母鸡生出
the eggs be a certain blue color. So she's like, I feed them blueberries. Okay. Now I had to, they sell out, you guys. These things sell out. I bought this months ago. You all get a Martha Stewart puffer t-shirt. What does that mean?
某种特定蓝色调的鸡蛋。所以她说，我喂它们吃蓝莓。好吧。现在我必须得说，这东西会卖光的，伙计们。这东西会卖光。我几个月前就买好了。你们所有人都会得到一件玛莎·斯图尔特的羽绒T恤。这是什么意思？
What is it? I got one for myself too. Here we go. Jenna, you got it in black. Uh-huh. You'll have to put them on. Cassie, you got a mercury color. It's called mercury.
这是什么？我也给自己买了一件。我们来啦。珍娜，你的是黑色。嗯哼。你们得把它穿上。卡西，你的是水银色。这叫水银色。
Oh, mercury. Tim. Okay. You got, oh, silver. Thank you. Thank you. And I got navy. I understand now.
哦，水银色。蒂姆。好吧。你的是，哦，银色。谢谢。谢谢。我的是海军蓝。我懂了。
It's just a short sleeve puffer jacket. It's a puffer jacket that looks like a t-shirt when you put it on. Instead of being a long sleeve jacket or a vest, it is a short sleeve puffer jacket. All right, hold on. I'll put mine on. I love it.
这只是一件短袖羽绒夹克。这是一件羽绒夹克，穿上身时看起来像一件T恤。它不是一件长袖夹克或马甲，而是一件短袖羽绒夹克。好吧，等等。我把我的穿上。我太喜欢了。
There's pockets. There's pockets. Oh my God, Sam, you look amazing. Oh, and the pockets are like fleece. Oh, yeah. Ooh, comfy. Did I get the right sizes? You sure did.
有口袋。有口袋。天哪，萨姆，你看起来棒极了。哦，而且口袋里面像是抓绒的。哦，对。噢，真舒服。我尺码买对了吗？你绝对买对了。
Oh my God, you guys look amazing. All right. Happy holidays, everybody. Thank you, Santa Claus. You're welcome. Thanks for having me. Good. That was amazing.
天哪，你们看起来棒极了。好吧，祝大家节日快乐。谢谢你，圣诞老人。不客气。谢谢邀请我。很好。太棒了。
Angela, you really brought it today. How'd you get all this stuff in here without me seeing it? I had to make two trips. How many bags of stuff did you bring in? I had to make two trips. I made one trip and hid stuff in our desk area. Okay. For a week.
安吉拉，你今天真的是放大招了。你怎么把这些东西弄进来而没让我看见？我跑了两趟。你带了多少袋东西进来？我跑了两趟。我跑了一趟，把东西藏在我们办公区域。好吧。藏了一个星期。
And then I brought everything else today. There are some other people exchanging gifts. They are Jim and Pam. It's finally time. They're in the break room. Yes. I am calling this Christmas in the break room. You know, we had a fan question from Bill S.
然后我今天把剩下的都带来了。还有其他人在交换礼物。他们是吉姆和帕姆。终于到他们了。他们在休息室里。对。我把这叫做“休息室里的圣诞节”。你知道的，我们收到了来自新罕布什尔州梅里马克镇的粉丝比尔·S的提问，
in Meramech, New Hampshire, and many others who wrote in to say, Pam and Jim are married and have a child at home. They presumably give each other gifts at home on Christmas Day, like families do. So why do they give one another their most special presence at the office? This has never made sense to me. It's a valid question. And if I am sort of living in the world of the show,
还有许多其他人写信来说，帕姆和吉姆已经结婚了，家里还有一个孩子。他们大概会在圣诞节当天在家像普通家庭一样互赠礼物。那为什么他们要在办公室里给对方最特别的礼物呢？这对我来说一直说不通。这是一个合理的疑问。如果我稍微代入一下剧中的世界，
Jim and Pam met at Dunder Mifflin, the first gift exchange they ever had that really meant something to the two of them for their relationship happened there. I could see it being sort of a very sweet couple tradition that they sneak away somewhere in the office and they give each other a gift. Because of that very first Christmas. Angela, that is exactly what John and I decided on set during this episode. Yay! We asked the same question.
吉姆和帕姆在邓德米弗林相识，他们进行的第一场真正对彼此的感情意义重大的礼物交换就是在那里发生的。我能理解这是一种非常甜蜜的情侣传统，他们偷偷溜到办公室的某个地方，送给对方一件礼物。因为那个最初的圣诞节。安吉拉，这正是乔恩和我在这集拍摄现场决定的。耶！我们也提出了同样的问题。
We said, why would they give each other their big Christmas gift at work? Yeah. It's a little odd, and we talked about it as a group, and that is exactly what we said. And the other thing we said was that it's supposed to be a homemade gift. So each year, in the tradition of the teapot and all of that, that they're going to exchange a little homemade item at the office. Remember, there was that whole deleted runner, that one Christmas episode, where Pam and Jim are making gifts for one another from things that they found in the office?
我们说，他们为什么要在工作时送对方最大的圣诞礼物呢？对。这有点奇怪，我们以小组形式讨论过，而这正是我们的结论。我们讨论的另一件事是，这应该是一件自制的礼物。所以每年，延续茶壶事件等等的传统，他们要在办公室交换一件自制的小物件。还记得吗，有个被删掉的废弃支线剧情，就是那一集圣诞节里，帕姆和吉姆用在办公室里找到的东西为彼此制作礼物？
Yes. So this is the tradition. That makes total sense. And then they might save other gifts for home, but at Dunder Mifflin, they give each other something they made. Yes. But of course, this year, Pam has really gone all out there, and she's made this comic book, and she's expecting that Jim has given her something.
对。所以这就是这个传统。这就完全说得通了。然后他们可能会把其他的礼物留在家里，但在邓德米弗林，他们给彼此送一些自己亲手做东西。对。但当然，今年帕姆真的是全力以赴了，她制作了这本漫画书，并且她期待着吉姆也送了她什么。
He gives her a box, and she shakes it, and she says, oh, is it pebbles from the beach in Jamaica? I loved how hard you shook the box, and he's like, hey, hey, hey, hey. Well, she opens it, and it is a beautiful diamond tennis bracelet. That Pam is clearly not expecting. No. But Jim did have a good year. Mm-hmm.
他递给她一个盒子，她摇晃了一下，然后说，噢，这里面是牙买加海滩的鹅卵石吗？我喜欢你摇晃盒子的那个狠劲，而他就像是，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿。好吧，她打开了，里面是一条漂亮的钻石网球手链。帕姆显然没有料到这一点。没有。但吉姆今年确实赚了不少。嗯哼。
We had a fan question from Michelle Q in Chicago. Is the bracelet Jim gives Pam the same one she's wearing in the finale? Yes, it is. We saved this. Like we told you how every character had a wardrobe, had a closet in the wardrobe trailer, Pam also had a jewelry box, and all of her most special things, her wedding rings, and her watch, and this bracelet would live there. And anytime there was an occasion to dress up, she would wear this bracelet.
我们收到了芝加哥粉丝米歇尔·Q的提问。吉姆送给帕姆的手链是她在结局里戴的那条吗？是的，就是那条。我们把这个保存下来了。就像我们告诉过你们的，每个角色在服装车里都有一个衣橱，帕姆也有一个首饰盒，她所有最特别的东西——她的结婚戒指、手表和这条手链——都放在那里。每当有需要盛装打扮的场合，她就会戴上这条手链。
I love that Pam had a jewelry box. Angela also had a jewelry box. Oh, yeah? Yeah. It mostly was cat earrings. And things like of that nature, things you might find at a cat con. Exactly. Pam is overwhelmed by this bracelet, moved to tears,
我太喜欢帕姆有个首饰盒了。安吉拉也有个首饰盒。哦，是吗？对。里面大部分都是猫咪耳环。诸如此类的东西，你可能会在猫展上找到的东西。没错。帕姆被这条手链惊艳到了，感动得热泪盈眶，
and now she is especially nervous about giving Jim her gift. But I mean, I don't know. But I mean, Jim loves it. He's speechless. Yeah. He loves her. I want to backtrack for one second. There is a scene I thought was so sweet.
现在她对送给吉姆礼物感到人格外紧张。但我的意思是，我不知道。但我的意思是，吉姆很喜欢。他感动得说不出话来。对。他太爱她了。我想倒回一秒钟。有一个场景我觉得太温馨了。
Michael is giving Woody a bath in the bathroom sink. What that sounds. Hey now. Hey now, Jenna. The doll. He's giving the doll a bath at 10 minutes, 51 seconds. There's a little tiny clothesline that Michael has made. And Woody's clothes are hanging on it in his hat and it's the cutest thing.
迈克尔在浴室的水槽里给伍迪洗澡。听起来真让人浮想联翩。行啦行啦。行啦，珍娜。那个玩偶。他在10分51秒时给玩偶洗澡。还有一个迈克尔制作的小小晾衣绳。伍迪的衣服和帽子都挂在上面，这简直是太可爱了。
I really loved Steve's performance in this little moment, I have to say. He just was doing it so earnestly and honestly, there wasn't a lot behind it. He was cleaning it. He was just trying to make something right. It was great. And then he's going to try to sneak out of the office without saying goodbye. Yeah. But Pam notices, she comes out after him and she says,
我必须说，我真的很喜欢史蒂夫在这个小片段里的表演。他演得是那么的认真和诚恳，背后没有什么花哨的动机。他在清洗它。他只是想把事情做好。太棒了。然后他打算悄悄溜出办公室，甚至不打算说一声再见。对。但帕姆注意到了，她追出来对他说，
I shouldn't tell you this, but AJ won't commit to Holly. And she's going to give him an ultimatum. She sort of says, I don't know a lot of happy marriages that start off with an ultimatum. And she tells Michael to just be patient and he's like, yeah, I can do that. Yeah. And they're going to walk back in the gift. Oh, oh, oh, what? What?
我不该跟你说这个，但AJ不肯给霍莉一个承诺。她打算给他下最后通牒。她有点像是在说，我不知道有多少幸福的婚姻是从最后通牒开始的。她告诉迈克尔要耐心一点，而他就像是，好吧，我能做到。对。然后他们要走回去拿礼物。哦，哦，哦，什么？什么？
It's scared the crap out of me. She did it. She did it. Oh my God. Cassie. Oh my God. She did it. Cassie.
吓死我了。她成功了。她成功了。天哪。卡西。天哪。她成功了。卡西。
Hold it up. Hold it up. It took two weeks. Cassie, get over here. Here it is, everybody. The clacky balls are free. Listen. Oh my gosh.
举起来。举起来。花了两个星期。卡西，过来。大家看，这就是它。咔哒球终于解开了。听听。哦，天哪。
Cassie in two weeks undid what a toddler did in 30 seconds, but I've had this a year and no one who came to my house could undo it. Yay. I can't believe that. My kids are going to flip out. Cade is going to flip out. Cade has worked the hardest at it. Oh my gosh.
卡西用两个星期的时间解开了幼儿在30秒内搞砸的结，但我有一整年了，所有来我家的人都解不开。耶。我真不敢相信。我的孩子们要疯了。凯德要疯了。凯德为了解开它付出了最多的努力。哦，天哪。
I didn't know it was going to happen and then it just, yeah, after a cocktail, it magically. After the F train to Brooklyn, it magically happened. It's a magic elixir. I mean, my kids are going to freak out. Like they are, they have tried so hard. One visit from Santa Kansan. I know. Wow.
我不知道它会解开，然后它就，是的，在喝了一杯鸡尾酒之后，它奇迹般地。在坐F线地铁去布鲁克林之后，它奇迹般地解开了。这是个魔法灵药。我是说，我的孩子们要抓狂了。他们，他们真的尝试了太久。圣诞老人金斯的一次拜访。我知道。哇。
What an episode. Woo. That scared the crap out of me. I know because Angela's back is to the door. So I didn't see Cassie. You're just screaming. Yeah, there was a Michael Myers element to it where she was behind you all of a sudden. Is someone going to attack me?
真是神奇的一集。呜。吓死我了。我知道，因为安吉拉背对著门。所以我没看到卡西。你只是在尖叫。对，有一种迈尔斯·迈尔斯（Michael Myers）式的惊悚元素，她突然就出现在你身后。有人要袭击我吗？
Okay. I don't know where we were. Well, I believe Michael was about to give Kelly her gift. Yes. Michael and Pam have come back into the party at 15 minutes, 12 seconds. We have a really hardcore, fakey bag. Oh, I can't believe I missed it. Oh, it's substantial.
好吧。我不知道我们刚才说到哪了。嗯，我相信迈克尔正准备把礼物送给凯利。对。迈克尔和帕姆在15分12秒时回到了派对上。我们有一个非常硬核的、山寨的包。哦，我真不敢相信我错过了。哦，挺厚实的。
But as Michael is trying to re-gift this Hello Kitty laptop sleeve, he overhears Holly and AJ. Yeah, AJ finds the Woody doll and he says it smells. What happened? And Holly makes up a total lie to protect Michael. She said it was her that spilled salad dressing on Woody. Blue cheese salad dressing. Yeah, stinko.
但正当迈克尔试图把这个Hello Kitty笔记本电脑保护套转送出去时，他无意中听到了霍莉和AJ的对话。对，AJ发现了伍迪玩偶，他说它有味道。怎么回事？为了保护迈克尔，霍莉编造了一个弥天大谎。她说把沙拉酱洒在伍迪身上的人是她。蓝纹奶酪沙拉酱。对，臭气熏天的。
So Michael kind of smiles. He realizes, you know, she's protecting him. Yeah. Michael is going to come through for Jada. He dresses up as the original Santa from the first part of the Christmas party and he asks her, what do you want for Christmas? It's a very sweet moment. Holly clocks it.
所以迈克尔微微一笑。他意识到，你知道的，她在保护他。对。迈克尔要为贾达挺身而出了。他打扮成圣诞派对前半部分的那个原版圣诞老人，他问她，你圣诞节想要什么？这是一个非常温馨的时刻。霍莉注意到了。
It makes us all hopeful. And the episode is going to end with such a creepy scene. Yeah, Jim doesn't want to leave the office. Earlier, he tried to form a truce with Dwight. Dwight did not accept and he has to leave now and he's scared. Remember the last time he was down in the parking lot, Dwight hid in a snowman and pelted him with snowballs until his nose was bleeding? Yeah, right.
这让我们所有人都充满希望。而这一集的结尾将是一个非常诡异的场景。对，吉姆不想离开办公室。早些时候，他试图与德怀特休战。德怀特没有接受，他现在必须离开，而且他很害怕。还记得他上次在停车场时，德怀特藏在雪人里，用雪球砸他，直到他的鼻子流血吗？对，没错。
Pam is like, come on, it'll be fine. And then they step outside and there are like 20 snowmen, creepy snowmen staring at them. Jenna, it gave me major squid game vibes. Yeah, you're right. It's like some weird part of squid game where, you know, they're going to attack you. We had a fan question from Kaylee D in Montreal, Canada, who said, what were the snowmen made of in the parking lot scene? How do you do this in the LA temperatures?
帕姆说，拜托，会没事的。然后他们走到外面，发现有大约20个雪人，诡异的雪人正盯着他们看。珍娜，这给了我满满的《鱿鱼游戏》既视感。对，你说得对。就像《鱿鱼游戏》里诡异的某个环节，你知道的，他们会攻击你。我们收到了来自加拿大蒙特利尔的粉丝凯莉·D的提问，她问道，停车场场景里的雪人是用什么做的？在洛杉矶的这种气温下你们是怎么做到的？
Kaylee, we talked a lot about this last week because it was very warm the week we were filming this episode and these snowmen were made out of real snow. Oh, Rainn Wilson, who directed this episode, said that the snow effects for this episode required 100 tons of chipped ice. Wow. In order to make these snowmen, the special effects team had built the metal molds and they hand-packed them. But unlike the one in the previous episode where the back was open so that Dwight could get in,
凯莉，我们上周对此进行了很多讨论，因为我们拍摄这一集的那周天气非常暖和，这些雪人是用真雪做的。哦，导演这一集的雷恩·威尔逊说，这集的雪景特效需要100吨碎冰。哇。为了制作这些雪人，特效团队建造了金属模具，然后人工将冰雪压实。但与上一集中背部敞开以便德怀特能钻进去的那个雪人不同，
you notice these are full snowmen. Because they run through them. And Jim, like, is attacking them with the umbrella and they're dense. Mindy said the snowmen took an entire day to build and they also took a lot of maintenance. And the biggest thing that they had to worry about were footprints. They had to make sure that the footprints were only one person. So, you know, even though it took many people to place all these snowmen,
你们注意到这些都是完整的雪人。因为他们要从雪人中间穿过去。而且吉姆，像是用雨伞攻击它们，它们非常结实。明迪说这些雪人花了整整一天的时间来建造，而且还需要大量的维护。他们最担心的就是脚印。他们必须确保脚印只有一个人。所以，你知道的，尽管需要许多人来放置所有这些雪人，
it had to look like Dwight did it himself. Oh my gosh, that's attention to detail, folks. Randy Cordray said for this whole episode, labor, materials, real and fake snow, making all the snowmen, the special effects budget was over $65,000. Well, there was a lot. There was a lot. But guess what? What?
但必须看起来像是德怀特自己一个人干的。天哪，伙计们，这就是对细节的关注。兰迪·科德雷（Randy Cordray）说，整集的劳动力、材料、真雪和假雪、制作所有的雪人，特效预算超过了65,000美元。好吧，确实有很多。确实有很多。但你猜怎么着？什么？
No one's going to pop out of these snowmen. Dwight is actually up on the roof. And he says, in the end, the greatest snowball is fear. Merry Christmas. And that's how the episode ends. Yeah. Pam and Jim are like just trying to make their way to their car. Jim starts attacking the snowmen.
没有人会从这些雪人里跳出来。德怀特其实在屋顶上。他说，归根结底，最棒的雪球就是恐惧。圣诞快乐。这一集就在这里结束了。对。帕姆和吉姆就像是在努力走向他们的车。吉姆开始攻击雪人。
We had a final fan question from Grace B. in Clinton, Arkansas. How did Jim and Pam get out of the parking lot? That was my question, because it's solid snowmen. They would have had to driven through it. Yeah. Grace said, this keeps me up at night. Yeah. Me too, Grace.
我们收到了来自阿肯色州克林顿市的粉丝格蕾丝·B的最后一个提问。吉姆和帕姆是怎么离开停车场的？这也是我的问题，因为那里全是实打实的雪人。他们只能开车直接撞过去。对。格蕾丝说，这让我整晚都睡不着觉。对啊，我也是，格蕾丝。
Grace, once I read your question and watched the scene, now it's all I can think of. I can't unsee it. Yeah, me too. Well, that was classy Christmas too, everyone. Next week, we're going to be back with Ultimatum. It is so good. A big thank you to Josh Snyder for this amazing F Train to Brooklyn drink. Thank you, Angela and Cade, for going to the CatCon and bringing us these lovely gifts.
格蕾丝，我一旦读了你的问题并看了这个场景，现在我脑子里就只有这个了。我挥之不去了。对，我也是。好吧，大家，那集就是“优雅的圣诞节”。下周，我们将带着《最后通牒》回归。那一集真的太精彩了。非常感谢乔纳斯·斯奈德（Josh Snyder）调制这款绝妙的“F线地铁去布鲁克林”饮品。谢谢安吉拉和凯德去参加CatCon并给我们带了这些可爱的礼物。
And Martha Stewart, thank you. Thank you so much for designing a short sleeve puffer jacket that you call a puffer tee. Yes, because it looks like a t-shirt, but it's a puffer. But t-shirts don't have zippers down the front of them. This one does, Jenna. How dare you. Which is why it's not a t-shirt. We also would like to thank Randy Cordray every week.
还有玛莎·斯图尔特，谢谢你。非常感谢你设计了一款短袖羽绒夹克，你称之为羽绒T恤。对，因为它看起来像一件T恤，但它是一件羽绒服。但T恤前面是没有拉链的呀，珍娜。这件有，珍娜。你怎么敢这么说。这就是为什么它不是一件T恤。我们还要感谢兰迪·科德雷，每周
He gives us the best behind the scenes details. We love you, Randy. And of course, Tonerad Riga, thank you so much for telling us about your comic book. And to Cassie for undoing the clacky balls. That was a big week. It was a big episode. You guys have a great week. We'll see you next time.
他都给我们带来最棒的幕后花絮。我们爱你，兰迪。当然还有托纳拉德·里加（Tonerad Riga），非常感谢你跟我们讲述你的漫画书。还有卡西，感谢你解开了咔哒球。那真是充实的一周。那是一集内容丰富的一节播客。祝大家度过美好的一周。我们下期再见。
See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to stitropremium.com.
到时见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西联合出品。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔执行制片。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的助理制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科伊。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉特恩的《橡胶树》。想要收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问stitropcomium.com。
For a free one-month trial at Stitropremium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在stitropremium上免费试用一个月，请使用优惠码：Office。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。